[Musique]
la séance est reprise mes chers
collègues des conclusions adoptées par
la conférence des présidents qui s'est
réunie le 30 juin dernier sont
consultables sur notre site du sénat
n'est pas reçue d'observation
je n'en vois pas en séance
ses conclusions sont donc à l'opt et
l'ordre du jour après une déclaration du
gouvernement suivie d'un débat en
application de l'article 53 de la
constitution
la première ministre nous vous
souhaitons la bienvenue pour cette
première intervention en tant que
première ministre au sénat dans le cas
de vos nouvelles fonctions et joue c'est
vraiment une sincèrement une pleine
réussite dans ses fonctions salut les
membres du gouvernement certains en sont
à leur deuxième séance du jour ici
d'autres ont des souvenirs
de cette maison et je leur souhaite la
bienvenue
je vous ai adressées madame la première
ministre hier un courrier proposant une
évolution des relations entre l'exécutif
et le parlement afin de concrétiser la
nouvelle méthode annoncé par le
président de la république notamment
dans son discours du 7 mai dernier je
compte sur votre prise en considération
attentif de ces propositions et nous
aurons l'occasion d'échanger mais sans
plus tarder je vais vous céder la parole
selon le ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement dont c'est
la première séance ou au sénat en tant
que ministre en charge des relations
avec le parlement madame la première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
il y à quelques heures j'ai prononcé
devant l'assemblée nationale
la déclaration de politique générale de
mon gouvernement
par respect pour nos institutions
par attachement pour notre part
parlement pour le bicamérisme par
engagement pour nos territoires
j'ai souhaité ce soir m'adresser à vous
de mes cinq années au service de l'état
de mes années pardon aux services de
l'état de mes cinq ans comme membre du
gouvernement
de ces premières semaines comme première
ministre
j'ai tiré une conviction qui n'a cessé
de se consolider
je n'imagine pas la république sans le
sénat
[Applaudissements]
ainsi madame la première vidéo
vous êtes à la fois les relais des
préoccupations des français
la voix des élus locaux et des
territoires la force d' équilibre et
d'apaisement de nos institutions
dans les urnes les français nous ont
appelés à trouver des solutions communes
et à répondre ensemble aux défis qu'ils
affrontent ils nous ont demandé des
débats francs mais respectueux ils ont
voulu des propositions fortes et
demander des compromis ils ont exigé de
l'action mais avant cela de l'ecoute des
forces vives des territoires des
français
bâtir des solutions ensemble
en écoutant les propositions de tous en
s'appuyant sur nos territoires en
restant fidèles à nos valeurs c'est la
méthode du sénat depuis longtemps
nous devons nous inspirer de
l'expérience et des pratiques du sénat
[Applaudissements]
à l'heure où notre
à l'heure où notre histoire politique va
connaître une nouvelle étape nous avons
plus que jamais besoin de vous
ce soir en m'adressant à vous je vous
parle avec responsabilité et humilité
responsabilité car les années qui
viennent de s'écouler ont été
éprouvantes pour bon nombre de nos
concitoyens
on a parlé d'années de crise j'ai
surtout vu chez les français le courage
la force de caractère et la volonté
grâce à eux la france n'a jamais baissé
la tête notre pays a tenu et je veux
saluer ici les deux premiers ministres
qui m'ont précédé edouard philippe et
jean castex
j'ai eu l'honneur de servir dans leur
gouvernement de mener avec eux des
réformes essentielles
à leurs côtés j'ai vu deux hommes d'état
qui ont traversé les difficultés et les
épreuves avec force et droiture ils sont
des exemples et je veux les saluer
responsabilité car nous connaissons tous
les défis devant nous l'invasion de
l'ukraine par la russie et le rappel
douloureux que la paix est fragile je
vous sais très attentifs monsieur le
président du sénat à la situation en
ukraine yens et vous serez dans quelques
heures à kiev
cette guerre a des conséquences
concrètes
l'inflation et la montée des prix de
l'énergie pèsent sur le pouvoir d'achat
des français les perspectives
économiques s'assombrissent
est par ailleurs l'épidémie de coville
n'a peut-être pas dit son dernier mot et
nous devons rester vigilants
le réchauffement climatique devient à
chaque seconde plus inéluctable
l'insécurité gâche encore le quotidien
le quotidien de trop de nos concitoyens
les inégalités territoriales sont autant
de fractures dans le pacte républicain
et menacent l'unité de nos concitoyens
alors nous avons la responsabilité
d'agir nous le devons aux français mon
gouvernement s'y emploiera avec force
ces dernières semaines à quatre reprises
les français ont choisi entre les
différents projets qui se présentaient à
leurs suffrages ils ont réélu le
président de la république puis ils ont
élu une assemblée nationale avec une
majorité relative
dans ce résultat nous entendons la
volonté d'un dialogue accru et de
construction commune dans le verdict des
urnes
il y a également des inquiétudes des
peurs des colères dans l'abstention trop
forte nous devinons aussi de la défiance
parfois de la résignation
beaucoup de français n'ont plus
confiance dans la politique et dans nos
institutions pour leur apporter des
solutions concrètes et changer leur
quotidien nous devons leur répondre cela
passe d'abord par une action résolue par
des résultats concrets qui se voit
échange le quotidien des français j'y
reviendrai
cela implique sans doute des changements
institutionnels aussi
mais on ne modifie pas nos institutions
sans consulter sans consensus
le sénat sera pleinement associé aux
réflexions et à la mise en oeuvre des
évolutions de nos institutions sous
l'égide du président de la république
une commission transpartisane sera lancé
à la rentrée pour y parvenir
répondre au message des français c'est
changer certaines pratiques
bad bâtir des compromis ce n'est pas se
renier c'est choisir de construire
autour de ce que nous avons en commun ça
n'est pas mettre de côté nos différences
c'est assumer les clivages et les
désaccords mais refuser les postures en
cela le sénat a été précurseur
mon gouvernement partage avec vous bon
nombre de priorités et même sans aucun
doute de solutions dans certains
domaines et pour certains textes au delà
de ce que la constitution prévoit le
travail parlementaire pourra commencer
dans cet hémicycle avant de se prolonger
à l'assemblée nationale ainsi le sénat
pourra pleinement agir comme force de
co-construction au service des
territoires et des français
[Applaudissements]
répondre au message des français cela
veut dire associés et donner la parole à
tous mon gouvernement consultera les
corps intermédiaires les forces vives de
notre pays nous mènerons chaque réforme
en lien avec les partenaires sociaux
nous serons à l'écouté de tous nos
compatriotes de leurs aspirations et de
leurs idées nous agirons surtout en lien
étroit avec les élus locaux
les élus locaux sont les premiers
interlocuteurs des français et les
meilleurs connaisseurs de leur
territoire ils sont les visages du
courage et de l'engagement ils sont en
première ligne face à toutes les
urgences ils sont les premiers
innovateur bien souvent précurseur pour
les mobilités pour la transition
écologique
la crise sanitaire nous l'a montré une
fois de plus pour aider nos concitoyens
ils étaient présents pour la campagne de
vaccination ils étaient présents pour
expliquer alerté accompagnés ils étaient
présents je veux rendre hommage aux élus
locaux pour chaque projet mon
gouvernement les associera les écoutera
pour chaque défi nous nous inspirons de
leurs idées et de leurs actions ils
doivent avoir de la visibilité de la
stabilité il n'y aura pas de grand
bouleversement dans les compétences des
collectivités
ils doivent avoir les moyens d'agir nous
définirons avec eux un agenda
territoriales en cherchant un accord sur
des objectifs et des moyens notamment
financiers
ils doivent avoir du poids le conseiller
territorial peut être l'occasion d'une
complémentarité plus forte entre
départements et régions
sur ce sujet
sur ce sujet nous lancerons des
concertations approfondies l'année
prochaine
surtout les élus locaux et plus
largement les territoires doivent
pouvoir prendre les décisions adaptées
au contexte local
je le crois fermement répondre au
message des français se lassent cela
passe par des solutions au plus près du
terrain les cinq dernières années ont
été l'occasion de premier pas nous avons
entamé le retour des services publics
partout dans notre pays plus de 2000
maisons france services ont vu le jour
notre objectif est simple pas un
français avec une maison france services
à plus de 30 minutes de chez lui nous
avons avancé dans le déploiement de
notre couverture mobile et haut débit
nous avons investi pour faire revenir la
vie et l'activité dans les centres
villes et les bourgs nous avons donné
aux collectivités les moyens de
solutions différenciées je veux dire ici
un mot de la corse le cycle des
discussions engagées avec les élus et
les forces vives sera relancé dans les
prochains jours il doit aboutir à des
solutions concrètes pour tous les corses
et notamment la jeunesse des solutions
concrètes pour le travail pour le
logement pour la transition écologique
pour le développement économique et la
sécurité
nous sommes prêts à ouvrir tous les
sujets y compris institutionnels allait
discuter en transparence dans un esprit
constructif et responsable mais ne
cédons pas à la facilité
répondons au cas par cas à ceux qui
bloquent dysfonctionne
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
vais vous proposer une méthode d'action
pour les années qui viennent il est
temps de rendre son sens au mot égalité
trop longtemps nous avons cru qu'il
signifiait qu'une règle unique dictée
depuis paris devait s'appliquer partout
toujours et sans adaptation possible
l'égalité réelle ce n'est pas un carcan
c'est nous fixer des ambitions communes
et trouver les solutions adaptées pour
les atteindre car mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs qui peut réellement
affirmer que les enjeux de santé sont
les mêmes dans le centre de lyon où dans
les banlieue de pointe à pitre qui peut
réellement penser que les écoliers des
quartiers nord de marseille font face
aux mêmes défis que ceux des villages du
calvados bien sûr il ya des enjeux
communs mais la justice territoriale ce
sont des solutions différenciées mais la
cohésion des territoires ce sont des
marges de manoeuvre donné pour la santé
pour l'éducation pour la transition
écologique pour la ruralité pour la
ville nous associerons les élus les
habitants des associations
avec eux nous dresserons des constats
avec eux nous trouverons des solutions
avec eux nous donnerons des moyens
je souhaite ici avoir un mot particulier
pour nos compatriotes d outre-mer il y a
quelques jours l'appel de fort de france
a été un nouveau signal d'alarmé les
outre mer c'est une jeunesse prête à
s'engager
les outre mer ce sont des trésors de
biodiversité
les outre-mer ce sont les places fortes
de notre souveraineté grâce aux
outre-mer le drapeau tricolore flotte
partout dans le monde alors dans les
outre-mers la promesse républicaine doit
être tenues avec les collectivités nous
agirons pour la présence des services
publics contre la vie chère pour le
développement économique et l'emploi
contre la délinquance et l'immigration
illégale
ce quinquennat sera également l'occasion
d'une nouvelle étape dans notre histoire
républicaine avec la nouvelle calédonie
j'y prendrai toute ma part
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'ai
confiance en nous et je suis déterminé
je sais la volonté constante du sénat de
bâtir au service de la france et d'agir
au service des territoires des français
cette volonté
mon gouvernement la partage alors
ensemble autour du projet du président
de la république nous allons dialoguer
échanger et construire les réponses aux
urgences et aux défis que nous avons à
relever le premier défi c'est celui du
pouvoir d'achat de nombreuses mesures
ont été prises depuis l'automne dernier
pour limiter la hausse du prix de
l'électricité du gaz ou de l'essence
c'est grâce à nos investissements
massifs que nous avons limité la hausse
des prix et l'inflation en france est la
plus faible de la zone euro mais nos
concitoyens ressentent encore chaque
jour les effets de la guerre les prix
augmentent et leur quotidien s'en trouve
affectée
c'est la raison pour laquelle mon
gouvernement présentera demain en
conseil des ministres des textes
d'urgence et des mesures concrètes
rapides et efficaces pour les ménages
nous prolongerons le bouclier tarifaires
sur les prix du gaz et de l'électricité
pour ceux qui travaillent nous
proposerons des baisses de charges pour
les indépendants le triplement du
plafond de la prime pont de pouvoir
d'achat et une aide pour ceux qui ont
besoin de leur voiture pour aller
travailler pour les retraités nour
valoriseront les pensions pour les plus
démunis les prestations sociales seront
augmentées pour les étudiants nous
allons revaloriser les bourses sur
critères sociaux pour les fonctionnaires
c'est le dégel du point d'indicé pour
les trois versants de la fonction
publique et nous pourrons discuter
ensemble des meilleurs moyens
d'accompagner les collectivités surtout
les plus vulnérables
ces mesures sont notre base de travail
avec mon gouvernement nous serons à
votre écoute et vous pourrez les amendes
et lors du travail parlementaire
mais je veux réaffirmer trois principes
qui doivent guider notre action
la responsabilité environnementale
d'abord il nous faudra systématiquement
mesurer l'impact de nos mesures sur
l'environnement la responsabilité
budgétaire ensuite je sais que beaucoup
qui tiennent dans cet hémicycle a raison
après avoir protégé les français durant
la crise nous devons retrouver des prêts
de perspectives claires pour
l'amélioration des comptes publics c'est
une nécessité pour continuer à financer
notre modèle social c'est un impératif
pour notre souveraineté
devant vous je peux se pose donc des
jalons clair en 2026 nous devrons
commencer à baisser la dette en 2027
nous devrons ramener le déficit sous la
barre des 3% je souhaite que nous
puissions travailler ensemble à
atteindre ses objectifs
nous vous proposons de le faire grâce à
une croissance forte durable qui créera
des emplois grâce à des réformes
essentielles pour notre pays grâce à la
lutte contre la fraude à la
modernisation de l'état et à des mesures
de bonne gestion
enfin notre troisième principe c'est le
respect de l'engagement pris par le
président de la république devant les
français pas de hausse d'impôt nous
l'avons fait durant le précédent
quinquennat en supprimant la taxe
d'habitation et nous avons baisser
l'impôt sur le revenu au total nous
avons diminué les impôts des français et
des entreprises de plus de 50 milliards
dès cet été nous vous proposerons la
suppression de la redevance aux deux
audiovisuelle elle ira de pair avec une
réforme de l'audiovisuel public qui
raque qui garantira son indépendance et
des moyens durables nous y travaillerons
avec le parlement je veux le dire aussi
ce combat pour le pouvoir d'achat nous
ne mènerons pas seules les entreprises
qui dégagent des marges devront aussi
prendre leurs responsabilités
notre deuxième défi c'est de bâtir
ensemble la société du plein emploi
vous connaissez ma conviction c'est par
le plein emploi et le bon emploi que
nous changerons notre rapport au travail
durant le précédent quinquennat nous
avons mené des réformes en profondeur
pour transformer le marché du travail
pour l'apprentissage pour la formation
des demandeurs d'emploi pour nos jeunes
avec le plan un jeune une solution et de
contrat d'engagement jeunes ces réformes
ont porté leurs fruits le taux de
chômage est au plus bas depuis 15 ans le
taux de chômage des jeunes au plus bas
depuis 40 ans
grâce à ce bilan le l'emploi est à
portée de main nous pourrons sortir de
la logique du chômage de chômage de
masse et redonner du pouvoir de
négociation aux salariés quand il ya des
tensions sur le marché du travail les
employeurs doivent être plus attractif
améliorer les conditions de salaires et
augmenter les salaires de travail a
augmenté les salaires
alors je vous propose de jeter avec le
gouvernement toutes nos forces dans la
bataille du plein emploi nous devrons
ramener vers l'emploi celles et ceux qui
sont le les plus éloignées du marché du
travail nous devons continuer notre âge
notre action envers les jeunes nous
devons permettre l'insertion des
bénéficiaires du rsa en assurant un
meilleur équilibre entre droits et
devoirs nous devons mieux accompagner
nos chômeurs aujourd'hui l'état les
régions et les départements avance trop
souvent en ordre dispersé nous devons
joindre nos forces et c'est pourquoi
nous transformerons pôle emploi en
france travaillent
le plein emploi enfin c'est permettre
une meilleure orientation des
l'enseignement secondaire et offrir des
formations tout au long de la vie c'est
ainsi que nous pourrons affronter les
défis de demain et formés dans les
prochaines années un million de jeunes
dans les métiers d'avenir notamment dans
les domaines de la transition écologique
et du numérique
enfin le plein emploi c'est la garantie
de continuer à créer des richesses et à
financer notre modèle social
nous dirons les choses clairement à vous
comme aux français notre système social
est un paradoxe à la fois l'un des plus
généreux est l'un de ceux où l'on
travaille le moins longtemps
aujourd'hui on part à la retraite plus
tard chez la totalité de nos voisins
européens
alors je le dis pour la prospérité de
notre pays et la pérennité de notre
système par répartition pour bâtir de
nouveaux progrès sociaux pour qu'aucun
retraités avec une carrière complète ne
gagnent une pension inférieure à 1100
euros pour sortir de situations où le
même métier ne garantit pas la même
retraite oui nous devrons
progressivement travailler un peu plus
longtemps
la réforme
la réforme que nous mènerons ne sera pas
uniforme elle devra tenir compte des
carrières longues de la pénibilité
de l'emploi des seniors cette réforme
nous la mènerons en concertation étroite
avec les partenaires sociaux et nouveaux
os nous vous associeront le plus en
amont possible
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
vous propose ensuite d'apporter des
réponses radicales à l'urgence
écologique
devant ce défi nous devons faire bloc
sortir de la querelle entre les radicaux
et les pragmatiques nous devons changer
nous adapter et bâtir une écologie de
progrès car la révolution écologique
permettra d immenses des innovations
fera émerger des filières nouvelles et
créera des emplois d'avenir nous avons
déjà fait des avancées significatives
mais pour atteindre la neutralité
neutralité carbone en 2050 et réduire
nos émissions de 55 % d'ici 2030 nous
devons avoir une action encore plus
résolue et organiser des concertations
seront lancés dès septembre pour bâtir
une loi d'orientation énergie climat
tout le monde doit en prendre sa part
tous les ministères
le ministre le président de la
république m'a confié la charge de la
planification écologique et chacun aura
une feuille de route climatique avec des
objectifs à tenir toutes les filières
nous définirons avec elle des objectifs
de réduction d'émissions un calendrier
et des moyens de les respecter tous les
territoires par leurs compétences des
collectivités sont au coeur de notre
transition écologique
bien souvent elles ont également été
précurseur
nous avancerons avec les élus locaux et
nous définirons des stratégies stratégie
adaptée avec eux c'est pourquoi nous
avons créé un ministère de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires
par notre action nous avons les moyens
d'être la première nation à sortir des
énergies fossiles nous y parviendrons
par un mix énergétique plus équilibrés
autour des énergies renouvelables et du
nucléaire
nous aurons besoin de piloter
parfaitement notre transition
énergétique
c'est pourquoi j'ai confirmé aujourd'hui
l'intention de l'état de détenir 100% du
capital d'edf
cette évolution permettra à edf de
renforcer sa capacité à mener dans les
meilleurs délais des projets ambitieux
est indispensable pour notre avenir
énergétique
nous mènerons la transition énergétique
aussi en consommant moins nous devons
nous préparer à toutes les décisions
possibles de la russie nous sommes moins
exposés mais nous serions tout de même
impacté par les décisions dès maintenant
nous nous préparons donc à tous les
scénarios je ne mentirai pas nous avons
les moyens de tenir mais il faudra agir
plus largement nous devons décarbonés
tous les pans de notre économie de notre
vie cela vaut dans l'industrie et nous
nous appuierons sur les 50 milliards
d'euros d'investissements d'avenir de
france 2030 cela vaut pour le logement
nous continuerons grâce au succès du
précédent quinquennat rénoverons 700
mille logements par an cela vaut pour
notre agriculture j'y reviendrai ce sera
le cas pour les transports enfin nous
voulons permettre à chacun quel que soit
le territoire où il habite d'avoir accès
à un moyen de transport propre nous
agirons pour le ferroviaire en
prolongeant les investissements de ces
dernières années pour les petites lignes
pour les trains de nuit pour les signes
du quotidien nous offrirons à chacun une
alternative à la voiture thermique
chaque français devra avoir accès à une
voiture zéro émission notamment grâce
aux primes à la conversion et à un
système de location longue durée à moins
de 100 euros par mois
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
sais que nous partageons l'ambition
d'une république de l'égalité des
chances
cette république de l'égalité des
c'est celle du refus de l'assignation à
résidence
celle qui rompt les inégalités de destin
c'est dès la naissance que tout se joue
par le chantier des 1000 premiers jours
comme par le service public de la petite
enfance que nous voulons bâtir avec les
collectivités nous voulons répondre aux
problèmes à la racine
notre objectif trouver des solutions de
garde pour les enfants de moins de 3 ans
offrir les deux cent mille places
d'accueil manquantes agir en particulier
pour les parents le plus souvent des
mères qui élèvent seules leurs enfants
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est agir aussi pour l'école
celle qui conforte les savoirs
fondamentaux
lire écrire compter
respecter autrui mais prépare aux
savoirs de demain comme le codage
informatique
celle qui garantit l'égalité et ne
renonce jamais à l'excellence celles qui
offrent des savoirs mais prépare aussi à
des métiers nous voulons rapprocher
l'enseignement secondaire et les métiers
et réformer le lycée professionnel
nous aurons à mieux associer les
enseignants à la transformation de
l'école nous devrons revaloriser leur
salaire et construire avec eux les
évolutions de leur profession dans la
ligne du plan marseille en grand lancé
par le président de la république nous
voulons donner des marges de manoeuvre
et d'adaptation aux établissements en
fonction de leurs besoins et de leur
territoire une concertation avec la
communauté éducative des élus les
associations sera lancée dès septembre
pour que notre jeunesse continue de
faire vivre les valeurs républicaines
mon gouvernement continuera à déployer
le service national universel
nous continuerons apprenons promouvoir
notre université et notre enseignement
supérieur
cela passe par un travail pour l'égalité
des chances par la simplification du
système de bourse par l'amélioration des
conditions de vie et d'études de nos
jeunes
construire l'égalité réelle s'est
partagé les moyens de l'émancipation
sport comme la culture à l'oeuf à l'aube
des jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
2024 il nous faut bâtir une nation
sportive qui partage le goût de
l'exercice physique du dépassement de
l'effort
à nous aussi de bâtir une nation
culturelle qui valorise soutient et
protège son patrimoine ses créateurs ces
industries créatives le pass culture est
une réussite aussi nous l'étendrons dès
la 6è et amplifieront l'éducation
artistique et culturelle
sans une santé de qualité
il n'y a pas d'égalité des chances en
ville comme en ruralité nous faisons
face à un manque de soignants et les
effets de la suppression du numerus
clausus ne se feront pas sentir
immédiatement
le défi de la santé c'est d'abord celui
de la prévention pour dépister pour
prévenir il nous faut agir ensemble avec
les élus et en particulier les maires et
activer tous les leviers qualité de
l'air habitat conditions de vie nous
aurons aussi à poursuivre le soutien à
nos soignants nous avons tous été les
témoins admiratif et reconnaissants de
leur engagement lors de la crise qu vide
le ségur de la santé a permis de grandes
avancées notamment en termes de
rémunération mais la situation est
encore loin d'être réglée pour cet été
nous avons pris des mesures d'urgence il
faut maintenant voir plus loin et
construire des solutions durables cela
veut dire entre renforcer l'attractivité
des métiers du soin permettre aux
soignants d'être au maximum auprès des
patients et renforcer la coopération
entre les professionnels de santé
à nous ensemble avec les élus locaux les
professionnels de santé les patients de
moderniser et d'adapter l'offre de soins
pour chaque territoire
des concertations seront lancés dès
septembre partout sur le territoire nous
l'on en priorité trouver des solutions
contre les déserts médicaux
je sais combien le sénat partage cette
priorité je veux ajouter mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que nous n'avons
pas encore tourné la page du coc vide
l'épidémie reprend ces derniers jours
elle reprend fort à l'heure actuelle
notre système de soin n'est pas impacté
nous devons toutefois rester extrêmement
prudent et vigilant
la république de l'égalité des chances
c'est celle qui offre une vie sereine à
tous les âges nous devons faire croître
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé et
assurer une meilleure prise en charge
que ce soit à domicile ou en maison de
retraite
cela passe par l'aménagement des
logements de nos aînés c'est le sens de
ma prime adapte et par l'amélioration de
la vie de nos aînés en maison de
retraite
après les témoignages insoutenable des
derniers mois sur les maisons de
retraite nous avons renforcé les
contrôles nous devons maintenant
construire des ehpad de demain mieux
médicalisé ouvert humains d'ici 2027
nous devons recruter 50 mille infirmiers
et aides soignants
ce défi est aussi immense qu
indispensable compte tenu de la
révolution démographique à laquelle nous
faisons face nous y parviendrons en
renforçant l'attractivité des
professions nous réussirons ce défi avec
les départements c'est ensemble que nous
bâtirons un service public du grand âge
à la hauteur
vous le savez le quinquennat précédent a
porté une attention particulière à
rendre notre société plus inclusive
le handicap c'est 12 millions de
français toutes nos familles sont
concernées toutes attendent que nous
poursuivions notre effort pour renforcer
l'accessibilité pour l'autonomie pour
une meilleure reconnaissance des
personnels de l'accompagnement nous
aborderons tous ces sujets lors de la
conférence nationale du handicap qui se
tiendra début 2023
j'ajoute qu'avec vous avec les
associations mon gouvernement réformera
l'allocation adulte handicapé en partant
du principe de la dea conjugale isation
il s'agira d'une réforme en profondeur
elle était très attendue
enfin je crois qu'il n'y a pas d'égalité
des chances sans sécurité
cette conviction je la tiens de mon
histoire de mon parcours je la tiens de
mes fonctions de préfet est je la tiens
de mes échanges avec les français comme
beaucoup de mots l'insécurité touche
d'abord ceux qui sont les plus démunis
elle brise des jeunes emporte des
familles elles touchent les zones
rurales comme les zones urbaines
l'insécurité est une inégalité une des
plus odieuses des plus inacceptable avec
mon gouvernement je suis déterminé à
agir
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
suis convaincu que dans ce domaine nous
pouvons faire beaucoup et ensemble nous
avons en commun la volonté d'assurer une
vie sereine à tous nos concitoyens nous
avons en commun le soutien la confiance
est l'exigence pour nos forces de
l'ordre durant le précédent quinquennat
des avancées ont été réalisées
dix mille policiers et gendarmes ont été
recrutés notre sécurité civile a été
renforcée nous avons prolongé l'action
menée depuis 2015 pour mieux lutter
contre le terrorisme et pour nos
services de renseignement je vous
propose d'écrire la prochaine étape
ensemble autour d'une loi d'orientation
et de programmation du ministère de
l'intérieur nous voulons agir plus
encore pour la sécurité du quotidien
préparer notre police aux défis du futur
notamment la cyber délinquance
amplifier encore notre lutte contre les
trafics pour y parvenir nous vous
proposerons de renforcer les moyens du
ministère de l'intérieur 1 pour mieux
assurer l'ordre républicain nous
créerons 11 nouvelles unités de forces
mobiles pour lutter contre ce que trop
de français vivent comme des zones
blanches de sécurité nous créerons 200
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie ce
défi j'y tiens je suis élu d'un
département rural jeu lady g était
préfète d'une région largement rurale ce
défi vous y tenez je sais combien la
chambre des territoires est attentive à
cette égalité devant la sécurité
mais les moyens supplémentaires ne sont
qu'une partie de la solution la solution
c'est aussi le refus de toute impunité
nous voulons doubler le temps de
présence des policiers et des gendarmes
sur la voie publique d'ici 2030 et
france réformer la filière de
l'investigation
la solution c'est aussi une justice
efficace rapide dont les décisions sont
respectées les états généraux de la
justice lancée par le président de la
république nous ont montré le besoin de
moyens et de méthodes nouvelles nous
voulons restaurer la confiance entre la
justice et nos concitoyens répondre aux
attentes des personnels garantir
toujours l'indépendance de la justice
pour aider les magistrats à faire leur
métier et ray nous nous recruterons 8500
personnels de justice supplémentaire
vous proposeront ces moyens dans un
projet de loi de programmation pour la
justice
nous voulons aussi que les peines soient
exécutées et lutter contre la
surpopulation carcérale
15000 places de prisons seront
construites dans les prochaines années
je veux dire ici un mode un sujet qui me
tient à coeur la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles sexistes et
intrafamiliales elle impose la
mobilisation de tous les acteurs forces
de l'ordre justice associations élus le
combat continuera je m'y engage
je souhaite également que nous
continuons à faire avancer dans notre
lutte contre toutes les discriminations
l'égalité femmes hommes notamment
la grande cause de ce quinquennat croyez
bien qu'en tant que 2e première ministre
de notre pays elle sera au coeur de mon
engagement
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
pandémie la guerre en ukraine les crises
migratoires nous ont rappelé que notre
souveraineté est à la fois profondément
française est profondément européenne
sans l'europe pas de vaccin pas de
sanction concertée contre la russie pas
de réponse efficace pour nos frontières
alors je vous propose de consolider
notre souveraineté au sein de l'europe
de bâtir une france plus forte dans une
europe plus indépendance cela passe par
la souveraineté énergétique
face au risque de dépendance au gaz et
au pétrole russe cette souveraineté
française et européenne se construit
aussi par l'industrie et le numérique
ces dernières années grâce à des baisses
d'impôts et des réformes courageuses
nous avons porté un coup d'arrêt à la
désindustrialisation
il faut poursuivre cette dynamique
c'est pourquoi nous vous proposerons de
supprimer la cvae dans la loi de
finances de 2023 cette mesure c'est de
la compétitivité pour nos entreprises et
surtout pour les pme et les tpe
en m'adressant à vous je devine votre
préoccupation
je le dis donc nous compenserons cette
perte de ressources pour nos
collectivités
notre souveraineté industrielle
c'est aussi investir dans des secteurs
d'avenir comme l'alimentation l'énergie
le spatial les bio médicaments ou
l'électronique
notre souveraineté c'est aussi une
recherche qui fait la fierté de notre
pays nous voulons continuer à valoriser
simplifier le métier de chercheur
notre souveraineté enfin c'est assurer
l'avenir de la filière agricole et je
sais combien ce défi vous importe c'est
mon cas aussi
avec les acteurs avec vous nous bâtirons
une loi d'orientation et d'avenir pour
notre agriculture
elle devra permettre de répondre à tous
les défis de l'agriculture et en
particulier les départs massifs à la
retraite des prochaines années c'est
d'abord une meilleure rémunération
c'est aussi le soutien à la transmission
des exploitations et à l'entrepreneuriat
c'est la poursuite de notre soutien
massif à l'adaptation de l'agriculture
au changement climatique avec
l'assurance récolte avec les moyens de
protection pour les années d
exploitation
c'est l'investissement pour de nouvelles
productions notamment les protéines
végétales
c'est la protection dans les accords
internationaux contre la concurrence
déloyale des pays qui ne respectent pas
nos critères sociaux et environnementaux
c'est une politique d'alimentation qui
respecte chacun des acteurs et leur
donne une juste rémunération
beaucoup a été fait lors du précédent
quinquennat nous devons continuer
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs une
france plus forte dans une europe plus
indépendante c'est également tenir nos
frontières au niveau européen nous
poursuivrons le travail entamé sous
présidence française
au niveau national nous resterons
fidèles à notre tradition d'asile mais
pour que cette politique soit juste nous
devons nous devons poursuivre
l'accélération du traitement des
demandes à ce que nous accueillons nous
devrons offrir une meilleure intégration
par le travail et nous devons aussi
reconduire plus rapidement ce dont la
demande d'asile a été refusée je veux le
dire aussi disposer d'un titre de séjour
en france impose de respecter ses lois
nous serons intransigeants
en matière d'immigration irrégulière
nous continuerons notre lutte à tous les
niveaux nous créerons une force des
frontières nous poursuivrons notre
combat contre les passeurs
il organise des véritables trafic
d'êtres humains ils doivent être
poursuivis et sanctionnés
une france plus forte dans une europe
plus indépendante enfin c'est notre
souveraineté stratégique le contexte
géopolitique est un rappel sévère nous
devons pouvoir nous défendre nous devons
pouvoir faire entendre notre voix
partout et dans tous les milieux nos
armées se battre pour notre liberté
parfois au péril de leur vie je veux
dire à nous armer notre confiance et
notre soutien
je veux leur rendre hommage et avoir une
pensée pour nos soldats tombés au combat
pour les familles endeuillées et pour
tous ceux revenus des terrains
d'opération meurtris dans leur chair ou
dans leur esprit
[Applaudissements]
le contexte et les désordres du monde
nous oblige nous devons disposer d'un
modèle d'armée complet équilibré
moderniser un modèle d'armée cohérent et
capables d'agir le précédent quinquennat
a permis un effort sans précédent depuis
la fin de la guerre froide pour nos
armées et nous avons respecté
l'exécution de la loi de programmation
militaire nous devons maintenant
poursuivre et amplifier cet
investissement prochainement le
président de la république annoncera les
contours d'une nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire
il donnera une vision et un cap à nos
armées comme à notre industrie de
défense nous tiendrons notre rôle nous
agirons en cohérence avec nos ambitions
européennes et nos alliés de l'otan
nous devons aussi fortifier la
résilience de la nation et par une
réserve renforcée par des actions auprès
de notre jeunesse par le travail sur la
mémoire par l'attention portée à nos
anciens combattants nous renforcerons le
lien armée nation
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
dans un contexte géopolitique bouleversé
dans un monde qui n'est pas encore sorti
de la pandémie dans un pays qui connaît
une situation politique inédite
nous avons des défis nombreux à relever
ma réponse notre réponse avec tout le
gouvernement sous l'autorité du
président de la république tient dans
une ambition forte et dans une méthode
nouvelle
dans les années qui viennent le sénat
sera plus que jamais au coeur de la
recherche de compromis et de la volonté
de construction
nouvelle étape commence et comme je lé
demandé aux députés tout à l'heure je
vous propose de bâtir ensemble nous
pouvons le faire
rassembler autour de nos valeurs celles
de la république la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité la laïcité
rassembler autour de la volonté d'agir
rassemblés autour de majorité dit et
rassembler autour de l'ambition de
rendre notre pays plus fort plus solides
mieux préparés pour affronter des deux
mythes les défis de demain j'ai
confiance en nous j'ai confiance en
notre capacité à relever les défis de
l'avenir ensemble
je vous remercie
la première mini
[Applaudissements]
si
dans la suite de notre débat mais je
vais donner la parole aux orateurs des
grosses
premier les orateurs
pour le groupe l'est républicain
le président bruno retailleau vous avez
la parole monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président
madame la première ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues madame la première ministre
nous avons écouté votre déclaration de
politique générale et nous l'avons
écouté très attentivement
non seulement parce que vous avez su
habilement flatter notre patriotisme
sénatoriales mais aussi parce que
rarement un tel exercice sera aussi bien
porté son nom
puisque à la crise géopolitique dont
vous avez parlé la crise encore
sanitaires à la crise sociale et
économique s'ajoute désormais en france
une crise politique une crise civique
est précisément
cette crise politique elle est générale
avec une france en fois de fracturation
et des français envoient de sécession
naturellement ce serait profondément
injuste
de mettre sur le dos des malais macron à
la fois cette fracturation et
cette sécession ce serait tout aussi
injuste de ne pas reconnaître que depuis
cinq ans tout s'est aggravé la
fracturation et la cessation la
fracturation s'est aggravée regardez la
carte électorale de la france lors de ce
précédent vote vous avez là l'image
d'une france en pièces détachées
jamais le vote des français n'ont
autant dépendu
de leurs revenus de leur diplôme de leur
âge de leur territoire un instant
vous aviez parlé de l'assignation des
français mais tout se passe comme si les
français est assigné dans leurs
différences
c'est un aveu d'échec et un terrible
paradoxe pour celui qui avait théorisé
la disparition souvenez-vous des
clivages les clivages sont de retour
chers collègues
ils sont de retour
plus radicaux encore dans leurs formes
politiques vous avez vu l'assemblée
nationale est peut-être plus dangereux
lorsqu'il s'échappe aux catégories
politiques alors madame la première
ministre vous devez et si vous voulez
vraiment réparer ces fractures
françaises vous devez parler aux
français comme un seul peuple
plus de français qui ne sont rien plus
deux premiers de cordée
plus de gaulois réfractaires réparer les
fractures françaises d'abord
cette fracturation qui s'est aggravée
et la sécession aussi qui s'est accéléré
elle s'est accélérée à cause de l'an
même temps un en même temps qui n'aura
rien réglé et qui aura tout abîmé
il n'aura rien réglé parce que
de zig zag en tête à queue ce président
virevoltant d'un revirement à l'autre
s'est enfermé dans l'impuissance
et jupiter s'est transformé en gulliver
pris dans les fils de ses propres
contradictions
je voudrais vous en donner un ou deux
exemples vous avez beaucoup parlé des
souverainetés la souveraineté
énergétique
vous avez fermer fessenheim une centrale
nucléaire et va on va ouvrir saint-avold
une centrale au charbon
bien sûr je vous ai entendu et nous nous
opposerons pas à priori contre la
nationalisation d'edf mais vous savez
que ça n'est qu'un moyen et que ça n'est
pas du tout suffisant traiter aussi la
question de la tarification de l'énergie
de l'électricité au niveau européenne
deux grands pays viennent de le faire au
mois de mai tout récemment l'espagne et
le portugal vous avez parlé la
souveraineté alimentaire de l'europe et
on vient d'apprendre qu'il ya un accord
de libre échange avec la nouvelle
zélande qui ne respectent pas en termes
de pesticides les normes que nous
imposons nous à nos agriculteurs
alors ça rime à quoi
madame la première ministre
vous voulez sans avoir pu solliciter la
confiance à l'assemblée nationale mais
vous voulez retrouver vous avez raison
la confiance pour les français si vous
souhaitez la retrouver renoncer allant
même temps fait des choix des choix
clairs les choix net une boussole un cap
c'est ce que nous vous demandons d'abord
et ça tombe bien parce que vous l'avez
sous-entendu vous l'avez même un peu
souligné
l'époque a changé radicalement le
président de la république avait parlé
d'un tournant avec le retour du trajet
tout fuit le retour du tragique c'est la
guerre en europe mais en économie je
cherche votre ministre mais on l'avait
votre place si j'ose dire cet après midi
le retour du tragique en économie c'est
quoi c'est le retour de la réalité ce
sont des taux qui ne sont plus négatifs
ce sont des taux qui sont en train de
s'envoler
l'inflation aussi qui les suit bien sûr
la croissance nous avait dit que la
dette serait remboursée avec la
croissance non parce que la croissance
fléchit parce que la parité entre l'euro
et le dollar est en train là aussi de
s'effondrer renchérissant l'inflation
importée bien évidemment donc il faut
abandonner le en même temps c'est à dire
renoncer à la politique de l'argent
facile
qui peut croire qui peut croire ici et
ailleurs pour ceux qui nous écoutent que
demain dans le monde les nations qui
compteront seront celles qui ont dépensé
sans compter qui peut croire un seul
instant que les nations qui ne tiennent
pas leurs comptes tiendront demain le
rang sur la scène internationale bien
évidemment le quoiqu'il en coupe tu
auras et et je le crois terrible pas
seulement parce qu'il aura beaucoup
coûté en centaines de milliards d'euros
la france des centaines de milliards
d'euros qui sont sans lien comme l'a dit
la cour des contrats plusieurs reprises
avec la crise du coc vide
ce qui aura le plus coûter dans le quoi
qu'il en coûte
à la france
c'est un changement culturel c'est cette
fausse croyance donner aux français et
vous l'avez dit à l'instant vous avez
parlé de rapports au travail c'est cette
torsion du rapport au travail que le
quoi qu'il en coûte à bouleverser faire
penser laisser penser aux gens aux
français que l'étape tous
qu'il peut pourvoir à tous et que
l'amélioration du sort de chacun dépend
in fine et de l'état ce qui est faux
plutôt que sa volonté personnelle plutôt
que des fruits de son travail
c'est ça la grande question madame la
première ministre vous n'obtiendrez rien
de nous rien si vous n'abandonnez pas
ce quoi qu'il en coûte et dès cet été et
dès cet été aidé dans quelques semaines
sur le pouvoir d'achat nous ne
cautionnerons pas de nouvelles dépenses
si elles ne sont pas gagé sienne ce que
nous ferons des propositions qui ne sont
pas celles ci voyez mon cher collègue
voyez je l'ait déjà annoncé mais nous
ferons des propositions sur les
carburants mais pas de nouvelles
dépenses s'il n'y a pas de nouvelles
économies pas de nouveaux chèques s'il
n'y a pas des mesures d'encouragement
par le travail parce que notre marque à
nous c'est de penser que le pouvoir
d'achat procède d'abord du travail et
non pas de chèques des chèques sans
provision fait par l'état
et d'ailleurs comment pensez vous lutter
contre l'inflation avec une politique
inflationniste avec des dépenses de
l'état qui n'ont d'autres objectifs
finalement que de subventionner des
emplois étrangers sur son taureau d'une
dépense de l'état vous le savez 62 euros
sont dépensés sur des produits importés
et vend en réalité engraisser l'emploi à
l'étranger en dehors de notre pays c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous voulons des
économies et nous voulons plus de
travail renoncer aux quoi qu'il en coûte
ces réformes est vraiment et vous avez
raison et nous vous suivrons si vous
êtes courageuse pas seulement à la
tribune mais dans les fêtes sur la
réforme des retraites nous vous suivrons
bien sûr parce qu'évidemment il faut
sauver notre régime pas seulement pour
nous mais pour nos enfants pour nos
petits enfants pour cette solidarité
dont souvent j'entends les uns et les
autres rob ashe et le refrain il faut le
faire concrètement et puis évidemment
les réformes des services publics nous
avons trois grands services publics qui
sont en déshérence la santé la sécurité
la justice vous l'avez dit aussi et puis
vous avez l'école ne pensons pas un seul
instant des chers collègues que la
dépense publique peut tout d'ailleurs si
la dépense publique était la mesure de
l'efficacité des services publics la
mesure de la qualité des services
publics avec 10 points de plus de pipe
par rapport aux partenaires européens
puisque vous avez parlé de l'europe
alors nous serions à l'avant-garde du
bonheur universel bien évidemment et le
ségur de la santé le ségur de la santé
illustrent ce contresens de façon
spectaculaire
il suffit pas dépenser des milliards
dépensés sans réformer s'est échoué nous
vous ferons des propositions sur
l'hôpital sur les déserts médicaux nous
avons déposé une proposition de loi ne
pensez pas un seul instant que de s'en
remettre aux élus locaux ce sera
suffisant non ce n'est pas possible nous
voulons une sécurité sociale qui soit la
même sur tous les territoires cette
égalité des chances c'est d'abord
l'égalité des chances devant aujourd'hui
un service public de la santé qui est un
service public à plusieurs vitesses vous
le savez
le quoi qu'il en coûte mais le en même
temps je disais n'aura rien réglé mais
il aura aussi beaucoup abîmé il a abîmé
les idées parce que désormais tout est
interchangeable
parce que désormais on peut passer d'une
conviction à l'autre il aura abîmer les
fidélités
à force de débauchage à force de
trahison
voyez je n'ai pas l'intention et je n'ai
pas non plus la prétention de penser un
seul instant que je détiennent la vérité
je crois que cette période et vous avez
souligné l'abstention doit nous inciter
à la modestie à à l'humidité
mais j'ai la faiblesse de penser que
l'honneur de la politique madame c'est
la force des convictions
et je pense que al'inverse le déshonneur
de la politique c'est quand on renie ses
engagements c'est quand on trahit ses
convictions eh bien nous ne trahirons
pas et nous ne nous retirons pas il ay
ay si des collègues qui ont des
convictions très différentes des miennes
mais ils ont des convictions et je les
respecte profondément parce qu'ils ont
ses convictions là est ce que nous
voulons nous dans la méthode de travail
que vous appelez nouvelle c'est parler
clair et parler clair si vous dire ici
solennellement devant quelques témoins
ce soir et bien que nous ne sommes pas
c'est une confidence macro nist
nous ne sommes pas nous ne le
deviendront pas nos électeurs ne le sont
pas non plus mais nous sommes patriote
nous aimons la france et nous voulons la
réussite de notre pays ça signifie que
notre ligne sera clair et sera exigeante
ce sera l'intérêt supérieur du pays et
nous pratiquerons une opposition bien
sûr mais une opposition d'intérêt
général vous l'avez souligné c'est ce
que nous avons l'habitude de faire vous
avez même dit que nous sommes des
précurseurs oui nous sommes des
précurseurs nous avons toujours à mende
et nous avons toujours proposé est bien
souvent les propositions que nous avons
faites sont tombés dans un silence dans
une indifférence parfois même méprise on
vous avait parlé de la vie conjugale
isation je pourrais vous parler aussi de
la laïcité de tant d'autres choses eh
bien ces choses-là oublié ou tomber
justement dans ce silence profond de
l'indifférence de certaines ou de
certains eh bien nous vous les
reproposons précisément par l'éclair
aussi c'est aller à l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est la france et les
français la france qui doit être
gouverné les français qui doivent être
écoutés une france gouvernée bien sûr
que la france elle est administrée elle
est sûre administrés jusqu à l'absurde
distant simplifiée débureaucratiser
c'est la clé de tout ça ne vous coûtera
rien ce sera des économies et ça sera
pour les français une planche d'appel
pour relever tous les défis que vous
avez souligné ici à cette tribune mais
si la france est de moins en moins
gouverner c'est tout simplement parce
que la politique de communication s'est
substituée à la politique tout court
même désormais la diplomatie même les
heures mais cher christian cambon la
diplomatie s'est réduit à n'être qu'une
affaire de propagande politique nous
voulons une france qui soit gouverné
nous voulons des français qu'ils soient
réellement écouter écouter les français
ça signifie revenir aux sources revenir
aux sources ça n'est pas vouloir
inventer des machins et des bidules plus
ou moins participatif qui bien souvent
ne sont des sessions de rattrapage pour
des recalés du suffrage universel
revenir aux sources c'est revenir à la
constitution l'article 3 la souveraineté
nationale appartient au peuple qui
l'exercé par ses représentants
mais aussi par la voie du référendum y a
pas besoin justement de conseil national
de la refondation la france
la france a des institutions pour
réformer elle a un parlement que 12 vous
devrez respecter en faisant moins deux
ordonnances et en les gratifiant 80% de
danse ne sont plus ratifié c'est une
entorse constitutionnel bien évidemment
mais aussi l un peuple la france un
peuple qui veut être écouté que de vous
devrez consulté beaucoup plus par la
voie de la démocratie directe sur des
grands sujets vous avez cité
l'immigration et la riche et le champ de
l'article 11 nous vous suivrons ce n'est
pas normal qu'aujourd'hui les français
sur des questions aussi importantes et
toujours été laissés à l'écart de ses
délibérations madame la ministre pour
terminer pour conclure général de gaulle
avait l'habitude de dire que la
politique c'est une action au service
d'un idéal vous nous proposez une
majorité de projets ça ne fait pas un
idéal je pense que si la confiance est
aussi bas aujourd'hui c'est parce que la
politique se refuse à viser haut à viser
haut toujours plus haut et bien et je
m'adresse non plus à la première
ministre si vous me le permettez mme
elisabeth baume j'ai entendu certains
qui indiquait que
vous aviez un profil trop technocratique
passé politique vous voulez que je vous
dise ici moi je vous dis solennellement
que la politique n'est pas une affaire
de profil que la politique c'est une
affaire de courage ce qu'on attend de
vous ici ce que les français voyez
attendre de vous c'est le courage de
relever la france c'est un courage qui
consiste à dire aux français croyez en
vous même croyez en la france et y est
la fierté d'être français
parce que la france c'est un combat
toujours recommencée contre la fatalité
madame la première ministre à chaque
fois que vous porterez l'intérêt
supérieur du pays nous serons là nous
serons aux côtés de la république en
côte est de la france
[Applaudissements]
hall
mais maintenant au président patrick
kanner pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste la république
parole monsieur président
monsieur le président madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
j'ai cherché un mot qui pourrait décrire
la situation politique dans laquelle
vous vous trouvez
il est toujours compliqué de résumer
l'état d'un pays il équilibre
institutionnel où le rapport de forces
au parlement par une simple phrase alors
avec un seul mot pourtant cela m'est
venu assez naturellement je pense que ce
qui caractérise la situation d'autres
gouvernements c'est le mot absence
c'est d'abord l'absence d'un projet
clair pour la france que l'on a
constatée dans les deux campagnes qui se
sont succédé la seule clarté dont vous
avez fait preuve concernés les
propositions de régression sociale le
conditionnement du rsa et la retraite à
65 ans
ensuite votre absence de colonne
vertébrale républicaine ne vous a pas
permis de tracer une ligne ferme face à
l'extrême droite
la main ne doit jamais tremblé devant le
risque d'affaiblissement des valeurs de
la république
cette absence cette absence de lucidité
cette absence de lucidité n'est que le
résultat de cette médiatique mais
funeste illusion cela bien être dit par
le président ohio du en même temps qui a
d'élite et le front républicain au
profit d'un front anti macron ces
différents éléments entre autres vous
ont donc contrainte à une absence de
majorité absolue pour gouverner
enfin que dire de l'absence de
considération à l'égard de la haute
assemblée dont manifestement aucun de
ses membres actifs n'a trouvé grâce aux
yeux du jupiter pour intégrer l'exécutif
j'ai bien dit membres actifs
j'arrête là ma démonstration
pour approfondir certains points que je
viens d'évoquer
cette séquence électorale laisse notre
démocratie exemple temps l'abstention
massive est devenu un fait politique
structurants qu'il convient de combattre
par tous les moyens nous ne pouvons nous
satisfaire de cette situation qui est
porteuse d'un danger majeur pour notre
république cette crise de la
participation n'est pas récente mais il
convient de constater qu'elle s'est
aggravée durant les cinq dernières
années après avoir théorisé mise en
oeuvre la fin du clivage gauche droite
après avoir maltraité marginaliser les
corps intermédiaires et les
contre-pouvoirs vous provoquez au bout
de ce chemin une déstructuration du
champ politique et l'accession de 89 89
députés du rassemblement national au
palais bourbon alors que la réduction de
l'influent de ce parti était l'objectif
affiché des politiques gouvernementales
en 2017 mais cette situation si
inquiétante soit elle peut-être
permettra le ferment d'un nouveau et
d'un renouveau institutionnel pour cela
il faut accepter et assumer la dynamique
parlementaire qui s'impose à vous madame
la première ministre il faut accepter et
assumer que les oppositions soient
reconnus et respectés dans leur capacité
à apporter des réponses aux défis de la
france d'ailleurs je regrette que vous
ayez refusé
de vous soumettre vote de confiance de
l'assemblée une motion de défiance
déposée par la gauche viendra la supplée
en partie mais c'est déjà l'aveu d'un
premier échec deux semaines des changes
avec les partis politiques et les
groupes parlementaires n'ont pas suffit
à vous assurer une majorité
cela doit vous amener à changer de
méthode vous devez réaliser que la
situation rend indispensable le respect
mutuel et en aucun cas les ultimatums
certes la constitution vous donne
beaucoup d'outils pour tenter
d'appliquer même en force une partie du
projet du président macron mais si vous
tombiez dans ce travers les répliques
social serait incontrôlable
les membres du groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains sont dans
l'opposition au gouvernement vous ne le
découvre et pas aujourd'hui mais nous
voulons avant tout le redressement de la
france et non son blocage avec exigence
nous cherchons l'apaisement et non la
crise pour entamer ce travail nous
aurons bientôt examiné un projet de loi
sur le pouvoir d'achat des français
l'inflation devrait continuer
d'accélérer pour atteindre 6 8% sur un
an septembre puis rester sur ce rythme
durant les derniers mois de l'année une
flambée qui va peser sur l'économie avec
une croissance qui peinera à atteindre
les 2 ennemis pour cent en 2022 et on ne
revaloriserait pas le smic les pensions
de retraite les minima sociaux le point
d'indicé à la hauteur de la souffrance
de millions de familles qui de plus en
plus tombe par exemple dans le crédit
revolving simplement pour boucler leurs
fins de mois au 1er proposition ne
compense même pas d'un station pour les
catégories concernées et monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
bloque toute ambition en déclarant que
nous avons atteint la côte d'alerté en
matière de finances publiques notre
ambition à nous éclaire
smic à 1500 euros et lancement d'une
grande conférence salariale dès
septembre pour préserver le pouvoir
d'achat des classes populaires et des
classes moyennes madame d'un premier
ministre
les premiers corvée veulent s'asseoir à
la table du pouvoir de vivre dignement
la multiplication des chèques ne fera
que des miettes
ce ne sont pas les miettes qui font le
pain c'est le pain qui fait les miettes
je vous invite à pétrir les moyens pour
financer cette ambition en renonçant à
une politique de rustines ses moyens ce
sont notamment la contribution
exceptionnelle des grands groupes au
financement des politiques publiques dès
qu'il ya super profits dans le cadre
d'une crise ou de tout autre conjectures
conjoncture qui le justifierait c'est
aussi vieillesse f climatique c'est
aussi l'annulation de la baisse des
impôts de production décidées lors du
dernier quinquennat
retrouvons les fondamentaux de notre
état providence devenu trop depuis trop
longtemps est à pénitence il faut
changer votre logiciel est considéré que
l'impôt n'est pas une charge mais le
vecteur de la redistribution
garantie du pacte social tel que défini
par l'article 13 de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen qui nous
rappelle un principe simple l'impôt doit
être également répartie entre tous les
citoyens en raison de leurs facultés
et pardonnez ma trivialité mais nos
services publics craque de toutes parts
il faut faire plus d'efforts pour la
police oui pour la justice oui plus
d'efforts pour l'éducation et la santé
comment peut-on alors justifier les 3000
postes d'enseignants non pourvus à la
rentrée comment peut-on justifier les
services d'urgence en pleine implosion
dans les hôpitaux alors que la pandémie
repart de manière inquiétante ces
efforts passeront par une fiscalité plus
juste voilà pourquoi le lien entre les
français leur service public doit être
retiré par l'investissement en priorité
dans les quartiers populaires nous avons
enfin un ministre du logement et de la
ville qui je le souhaite corrigera le
bilan indigents du précédent quinquennat
mais encore plus impactés par ce
sentiment d'abandon sont les zones
rurales la multiplication des déserts
médicaux des déserts numérique les
questions de mobilité d'accès aux
services amène nos concitoyens vivent
dans ces territoires à être excédés à
juste titre par ces inégalités de
traitement les fractures se creuse où la
victime d'un premier ministre et se
traduisent par une colère démocratique
mais il n'y a pas de fatalité
l'état peut y remédier il doit y
remédier car la côte d'alerté bien
atteindre pour nos services publics mais
pour résoudre ce problème ce n'est pas
dans la poche des collectivités qu'il
faut aller chercher les moyens du
redressement mais dans celle du cac 40
qui a versé l'an dernier plus de 80
milliards d'euros de dividendes ou
encore dans celle des évadés fiscaux
ou encore dans celle des évadés fiscaux
qui ont fait perdre tout autant au
budget de l'état
le programme que vous souhaitez
appliquer envers les collectivités
territoriales d'ailleurs symptomatique
de votre dogmatisme sur le sujet les
collectivités ont déjà fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour contribuer au
redressement des comptes publics on leur
a déjà beaucoup demander peut-être trop
je le concède aussi envisager une
suppression de la cvae c'est empêcher
une nouvelle fois les collectivités
d'avoir les moyens de leurs ambitions
opéré des coupes sombres par petites
touches n'est pas conforme à ce que doit
être fait par les collectivités qui ont
su
toujours lors de crises compenser les
carences de l'état et continue à
supporter de nouveaux transferts de
compétences c'est aussi cela madame la
premier ministre l'indivisibilité de la
république qu aucune différenciation ne
doit menacer
profitons profitons de cette
parlementarisation de la vie politique
pour porter ensemble parlementaires et
élus locaux une remise à plat des
ressources et une refonte de l'autonomie
fiscale et financière lourdement impacté
par la pratique des dotations je réitère
ici la nécessité d'une loi de finances
spécifique aux collectivités locales qui
représentent plus de 20 % de la dépense
publique nous y constate aurions que
dépourvus de moyens dynamique
les collectivités territoriales seront
dans l'incapacité
dans la capacité d'être à la hauteur des
défis que nous avons soulevé que ce soit
le soutien du pouvoir d'achat des
français la lutte contre le chômage la
contribution à la réforme de la
dépendance dont la grande loi tant
promise et si nécessaire se fait
finalement toujours attendre ou encore
la planification etc logique énergétique
je souhaite revenir sur ce dernier point
la politique environnementale et votre
manque d'ambition en ce domaine s'est
traduite encore il ya deux jours par la
rétrogration la rétrogradation
symbolique de la 5e à la 10e place du
ministre de l'environnement dans l'ordre
protocolaire
pourtant nous n'avons plus le temps de
tergiverser sur la question
environnementale en ce domaine il n'y a
pas d'alternative possible pour les
générations futures les canicules ou
orage dantesque à répétition ne nous
laisse pas le choix les glaciers qui
s'effondre ne nous laisse pas le choix
les rapports du giec ne nous laisse pas
le choix sinon celui d'un effort
politique immense a mené dès aujourd'hui
pourtant vous avez choisi de reculer
cela dans l'ordre de vos priorités un
nouveau recul après cinq ans de
renoncement parmi lesquelles entre
autres le glyphosate le soutien aux
énergies fossiles le non respect des
accords de paris ou encore le refus
d'accepter de mettre en oeuvre une
véritable éco conditionnalité des aides
dans les plans de relance successifs
comme nous vous l'avions pourtant
proposé nous ne voulons pas madame juste
de l'écologie nous voulons une écologie
juste et la nationalisation d'edf dont
84% appartient déjà à l'état relève plus
de l'évolution que de la révolution dans
la même veine l'annnonce de votre
gouvernement est une mauvaise surprise
pour nos concitoyens ultramarins
la rétrogradation des ministres d
outre-mer en ministère délégué auprès du
ministre de l'intérieur est une erreur
ces territoires n'ont pas besoin d'une
orientation martial des politiques de
l'état mais d'une feuille de route sur
l'amélioration du pouvoir d'achat du
développement économique du renforcement
des services publics ou encore la
résilience écologique les outre mer ne
veulent pas entendre parler de promesse
républicaine mais constater in concreto
l'équité républicaine
la nomination de votre gouvernement est
également une mauvaise nouvelle pour la
parité
le tour de passe passe entre ministres
et secrétaires d'état n'a eu qu'un effet
bien visible amoindrir pour la première
fois depuis dix ans depuis 10 ans le
nombre de femmes ministres de plein
exercice mes reproches sont nombreux nos
différences sont profondes vous pouvez
le constater
pour autant comme je voulais dit les
membres de mon groupe sauront être une
opposition constructive le contexte ne
me permettrais pas autrement une autre
solution oui la nouvelle donne politique
vous pousse au compromis les français
voulons demander on ne vous ayant pas
octroyer une majorité absolue alors j'ai
quelques questions à vous poser monsieur
le président pour terminer oui ou non
allez vous revenir sur votre réforme
inique de l'assurance chômage oui ou non
acceptez-vous d'abandonner votre projet
mortifère de recul de l'âge légal de la
retraite à 65 ans oui ou non
maintenez-vous la suppression pure et
simple de la redevance audiovisuelle et
de ses 3 milliards d'euros de recettes
oui ou non accepter vous de mettre en
place à denis sf climatique oui ou non
acceptez-vous d'ouvrir les minima
sociaux des 18 ans oui ou non
acceptez-vous de taxer les super profits
et d'appeler à la solidarité des foyers
fiscaux les plus aisés qui ont tous
bénéficié du bouclier fiscal du
précédent quinquennat madame la ministre
vous avez été l'actrice active d'un
gouvernement dont par votre discours
finalement vous assumez les
insuffisances en terme de bilan
dont acte nous vous donnons acte aussi
de votre projet politique ce n'est pas
le nôtre les français en seront témoins
et finalement les juges à votre
république de l'égalité des chances au
caractère si formel nous défendrons
toujours les actes pour une égalité
réelle compter sur notre groupe pour
vous le rappeler en permanence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci dieu dès maintenant la la parole
pour le groupe de l'union centriste
au président
hervé marseille
[Applaudissements]
donc
merci monsieur le président madame la
première beneath mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je dois
vous dire madame la première ministre
que j'ai été émue en entendant vos
propos concernant le sénat
il faut dire qu'ici et faisons partie
d'une communauté martyrisé qui a pas eu
souvent l'occasion
d'entendre des ministres et encore moins
première ministre s'exprimer avec autant
de tendresse vis-à-vis de nous
j'avais l'impression
j'avais l'impression d'être dans un
monde metaverse je me dis c'est pas
possible alors je suis sûr madame la
première mini ce que vous allez
apprécier le sénat
après quelques passages à l'assemblée
nationale que vous avez inauguré
aujourd'hui
tel ulysse chahuté par la tempête les
rivages de la haute assemblée vous
semblez particulièrement paisible
madame la première ministre beaucoup
vous connaissent ici comme une
interlocutrice attentive et je formule
le voeu que matignon n'est en rien
entamé vos qualités d'écouté de dialogue
car de l'ecoute il va en falloir les
électeurs ont opté pour le grand
chamboule tout institutionnels ils ont
ressuscité la république parlementariste
de 1958 dans la république
présidentialiste de 1962 consolidé en
2002 ils ont imposé un indispensable
dialogue entre les forces politiques en
remettant le parlement au centre du jeu
la disruption à la mode en 2017 est
synonyme de catastrophe cinq ans plus
tard beaucoup crié à la faillite des
institutions il convoque parfois le
spectre de l'immobilisme du blocage de
la parade ici que se passe-t-il de si
grave pour que certains s'en inquiètent
la majorité présidentielle oui n'a plus
la majorité elle ne détient que 44 % des
sièges à l'assemblée nationale j'observe
pour autant que le spd du chancelier
olaf scholz n'en a que 28 % au bundestag
et que le pse de pedro sanchez n'en a
que 34 % aux cortès madame le premier
ministre pourquoi serions nous les seuls
à ne pas savoir recherché
compromis des accords pour aboutir
au fond cette situation peut surprendre
c'est la situation normale en démocratie
représentative est sans doute allons
nous découvrir que le parlementarisme
peut très bien fonctionner et même être
vertueux car il nous forcera à légiférer
- pour légiférer mieux par exemple sans
ordonnance à condition
à condition de se désintoxiquer du fait
majoritaire et de ses facilités
autrement dit ne plus considérer des
assemblées comme des chambres
d'enregistrement d'un régime
présidentiel
et parallèlement mais cela a été dit par
les orateurs précédents ne pas
contourner ou dévaloriser ces mêmes
assemblées en multipliant des comités
théodule les députés et les sénateurs
ont la légitimité du suffrage universel
le cee dans la constitution il est
césaire représentent les forces vives du
pays
la constitution nous offre toutes les
institutions nécessaires pour débattre
pas besoin d'un probable convention
citoyenne aussitôt constitué aussitôt
congédié source de confusion un
parlement fort
[Applaudissements]
un parlement fort n'a pas besoin des
racks oui à la convention transpartisane
pour les institutions nos conseils de la
refondation
je fais
je fais le pari qu'un parlement vivant
créatif sera le meilleur vecteur
pourrait intéresser les français à la
vie politique du moins en forme le voeu
car je n'oublie pas que plus d'un an
inscrits sur deux n'est pas allé voter
et que la représentation issu des
élections est certes bien plus conforme
à celle du corps électoral mais n'est
pas encore totalement proportionnelle
pour que le parlementarisme fonctionne
de nouveau il faut que l'exécutif
apprennent à être plus constructif ce
que nous faisons au sénat depuis bien
longtemps madame la première ministre
bienvenue dans notre monde cet esprit
constructif que vous revendiquez nous
l'avons toujours pratiqué même si
certains prétendent ne s'en est jamais
rendu compte nous avons seulement été
une assemblée qui devait régulièrement
défendre son existence mais depuis que
vous avez parlé on a retiré des sacs de
sable aux fenêtres voilà
qui avait le culot de faire des
propositions et de contrôler l'action de
l'exécutif qui était tellement
intolérante que les deux tiers des
projets de lois ont été adoptées avec
notre soutien qui était tellement
intransigeant que nous avons voté toutes
les lois d'urgence sanitaire la recette
est simple concernés présentent
concertée très en amont proposé concédé
et écouter le terrain au fond nous
n'avons pas le choix
nos concitoyens ne supporte plus la
verticalité jupitérienne mais ne
tolérons pas non plus l'inaction et ils
auront raison compte tenu de la
situation du pays l'immobilisme est un
luxe dont nous n'avons pas les moyens
les campagnes présidentielle et
législatives n'ont pas permis de faire
émerger un véritable projet nous
découvrons aujourd'hui les intentions de
votre gouvernement voici quelques
considérations auxquelles notre groupe
est attaché la situation sociale est
explosive
elle a été contenue par un quoi qu'il en
coûte parmi les plus généreux de la
planète mais l'inflation surtout
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie a
de quoi remettre de ce haut pour la
répartition des richesses des richesses
est choquant nos concitoyens ne supporte
plus les inégalités et l'indécence de
certains privilégient nous proposerons
de taxer les super profits générés par
la crise pétrolière
nos services publics écoles hôpitaux
sont dégradées vous l'avais dit après
des années de croyance qu'un bon budget
est un budget aux moyens accrus pour
faire très simple nous n'avons pas de
divergences notables sur les sujets de
politique étrangère d'ambition
européenne de défense nationale sur
l'avenir de la nouvelle calédonie sur la
violence qui affleure partout dans la
société nous prenons acte de votre
volonté d'agir encore plus et toujours
plus
quant à la désertification médicale dont
vous venez de parler la traiter par la
seule prévention ne suffira pas des
réformes de structure s'impose et je
pense notamment au rapport de mon ami
mort et et à ses conclusions qui ont
permis de réfléchir à la régulation de
l'installation des médecins comme cela
se pratique en allemagne depuis
longtemps l'un des rares sujets ayant
émergé des campagnes et celui des
retraites et nous approuvons la
nécessité d'une réforme vous avez
habilement évité de citer un âge de
départ à la retraite tout en mentionnant
la cité la part dans la nécessité de
travailler plus pour nous le paramètre
juste et celui de la durée de cotisation
dans un régime assurantiel c'est bien
lui qui détermine le niveau des droits
c'est dans cette direction que nous vous
proposons d'aller cette réforme est
susceptible d'intervenir alors que la
situation budgétaire du pays est
extrêmement préoccupante mais nos moyens
d'action sont amputés il n'est pas
envisageable d'augmenter les
prélèvements il faut donc agir sur les
dépenses soutenir le pouvoir d'achat
bien sûr à condition de n'aider que ceux
qui en ont impérativement besoin et de
commencer à faire des économies
correspondante l'illusion de l'argent
magique ne doit pas perdurer notamment
au détriment des collectivités locales
elles ne doivent plus servir de variable
d'ajustement par exemple la suppression
annoncée de la redevance télévision ne
peut pas se faire au prix d'une ponction
sur les dotations des collectivités
territoriales
puisque nous cherchons des économies
acceptant d'être moins pointilleux sur
les normes qui souvent contraignent nos
collectivités enfin nous partageons
votre regard sur l'état de la planète le
réchauffement climatique l'effondrement
de la biodiversité les pollutions en
tout genre comme vous nous considérons
que la décroissance n'est plus une
option c'est socialement et humainement
impraticable en france et partout
ailleurs nous croyons à la puissance de
l'innovation pour sortir par le haut des
contradictions de notre modèle mais
comme vous l'avez dit nous ne pourrons
pas le faire sans le nucléaire la crise
l'ukrainienne là encore cruellement
rappelé nous ne pouvons que nous en
réjouir mais nous ne sommes pas pour
autant sorti de l'ambigüité six paires
en projet ferme c'est peu il va falloir
aller plus loin par ailleurs la
limitation de la part du nucléaire à 50
% du mix électrique est toujours de mise
enfin il faudra sûrement prolonger les
réacteurs actuels les plus le plus
possible comme aux états unis faute de
quoi il nous faudra recourir au gaz ou
même au charbon comme en témoigne la
réouverture de saint-avold et donc
faillir à nos obligations de réduction
d'émissions carbone dans le même esprit
de responsabilité de réalisme nous
entendons la nécessité de limiter
l'artificialisation des terres mais nous
nous opposons totalement à une approche
dogmatique qui fige les territoires les
décrets d'application de la loi climat
et résilience sont inapplicables et
inacceptable pour beaucoup d'élus par
exemple il est absurde que les grands
travaux d'intérêt national cannibalise
le potentiel d'artificialisation de
toute une région qui doivent être versés
dans une enveloppe nationale et opère
une péréquation
en un mot ce qu'il faut retravailler
d'urgence en concertation avec les
collectivités
ce n'est pas l'objectif de la zad mais
les moyens d'y parvenir je donnais la
madame la première ministre quelques
exemples des dossiers qui nous attendent
les plus en vue pour illustrer d'état
d'esprit qui nous anime rares madame la
première ministre vous avez dit que vous
aviez une boussole bâtir pour le pays
certains plus érudite moir ont convoqué
le général de gaulle d'autres l'esprit
boulanger avec les miettes et le pain
vous me permettrez de terminer en
faisant une invocation et en citant un
autre un auteur que nous aimons au sénat
le président larcher nous le disons
mais oui
c'est mieux ici
nous ne disons jamais oui par discipline
et non par dogmatisme donc vous avez
bien compris que nous souhaitons
travailler dans l'intérêt du pays et
chaque fois que vous voudrez bien nous
travaillons avec cet état d'esprit bravo
président
[Applaudissements]
plutôt président patriat pour le groupe
du rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole monsieur le président madame
madame la première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues nous avons été nous
aussi sensible madame la première
ministre message que vous avez envoyé au
sénat
même s'il n'est pas toujours facile d'y
affirmer son soutien au gouvernement je
vais essayer de m'y atteler modestement
leur
sirh collègues l'heure elle est à la
gravité l'heure est à la responsabilité
malheur aussi est à l'ambition
c'est dans un contexte inédit que
s'inscrit la démarche du gouvernement
que vous venez de nous proposer une
guerre en europe qui continue de faire
rage une pénurie de matières premières
une inflation continue une hausse des
prix de l'énergie une insécurité
alimentaire les étés croissant du
dérèglement climatique soit parlé de la
pandémie cette situation appelle de
notre part à la fois de la lucidité du
courage politique
le vote aux dernières élections
législatives
rey fait de vraies inquiétudes et révèle
de profondes fractures qui ont été
évoqués par certains d'entre vous en
accordant la majorité absolue à aucune
force politique les françaises et les
français ont souhaité renforcer le poids
du parlement dans l'élaboration de
réforme de la décision politique
malgré tout seul la majorité
présidentielle est en mesure de
gouverner le pays il n'ya pas d'autre
alternative à ce jour ce message a été
reçu par le gouvernement d'élargir le
dialogue les oppositions nationale ne
l'ayant pas souhaité il n'y aura pas
d'accord de gouvernement il n'y aura pas
de coalition c'est donc texte par tex
que nous devrons construire des
compromis exigent plusieurs fois choix
s'offraient à nos deux chers collègues
l'action ou l'immobilisme le dépassement
ou les postures délétère la volonté ou
la fatalité le courage ou la facilité le
pire serait l'affrontement ou le refus
du dialogue privilégié les postures
partisanes pour durer notre pays à la
stagnation ou au pire au recul les
français ne nous le pardonnerait pas
c'est donc en responsabilité que le
groupe r des pays fait le choix à vos
côtés de l'action déterminée en un mot
construire ensemble comme vous le
proposez madame la premier ministre je
suis convaincu mes chers collègues que
l'ensemble de nos groupes pour vocation
à agir dans ce sens nous avons su lors
des dernières sessions parlementaires
trouver des compromis sur les textes
essentiels le nombre de commissions
paritaires conclusive au cours du
dernier quinquennat en témoigne à court
terme l'art du compromis fera mentir
tous ceux qui pensent que la france
n'est pas réformable et que les
politiques sont voués à la puissance à
long terme pouvons nous espérer
réconcilier les français avec leurs élus
mes chers collègues madame la première
ministre il nous faut gagner la bataille
contre cet ennemi mortel du progrès qu
est la résignation il nous appartient de
ramener à l'espérance ces jeunes ces
femmes ces hommes de tous horizons
politiques qui ont préféré s'abstenir ou
pire se tourner vers les extrêmes
populiste contre cet abandon du terrain
au mauvais vent nous devons nous
efforcer de faire partager notre goût de
l'action au service de l'état qui ne
peut être réellement protecteur que si
l'état qui s'il est en état
investisseurs catalyseur d'énergie et
accompagnateurs d'initiative c'est à ce
point d' équilibre entre liberté sans
laquelle on s'éteint ou la protection
sans laquelle on devient victime qui est
notre idéal de progrès nous sommes là
pour participer
l'application du projet proposé par le
chef de l'état et souhaité par les
français un projet cohérent un projet
crédible un projet financé nous devrons
donc travailler ensemble en matière
d'urgences é cologie de plein emploi de
santé et de sécurité je ne doute pas que
nous serons discerner les priorités à
resserrer dans les textes moins bavard
souvent c'est vrai tout le monde le dit
nous légiférons trop et bien essayé de
pallier à ce problème notre seul
objectif c'est de défendre l'intérêt
général de participer au redressement du
pays et de choisir la voie du progrès
comme la premier ministre retenu vos
priorités la volonté de protéger les
françaises et les français et de
construire l'avenir le travail de fond
mené depuis 2017 a permis d'obtenir des
résultats positifs un taux de chômage
plus bas au plus bas depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années l'autochtone à taux de
croissance qui résistent une économie
toujours plus attractive une inflation
annuelle qui est la plus faible de la
zone euro saluons également les chiffres
ils appartiennent de l'apprentissage et
de la réussite du programme à jeunes une
solution désormais l'urgence et à la
lutte contre les effets de la hausse des
prix et à léquilibre nos comptes publics
c'est par le travail par la croissance
et l'emploi que nous réduirons notre
déficit et pas seulement par
l'orthodoxie budgétaire qui certes est
nécessaire mais qui ne vise pas
seulement décourager les français par la
peau et par les charges je rappelle que
l'objectif du gouvernement est de créer
du progrès social sans augmenter les
impôts et en maîtrisant la dette cet
objectif doit nous réunir les mesures
emblématiques du texte pouvoir d'achat
sur lequel nous sont amenés à débattre
que vous avez évoquées vont y participer
le gouvernement doit entendre ce message
beaucoup de français pardon et notamment
les plus jeunes se sont emparés de
l'urgence climatique le gouvernement a
entendu ce message si je vous ai écouté
les actions efficaces ont pourtant déjà
été prises elles sont pas suffisamment
relevé ma prime rénove la reconversion
des véhicules la lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols la
production décarbonée la fin
d'exploitation des hydrocarbures la
lutte contre les grands barrages
plastique devons poursuivre ses efforts
les leviers d'adaptation juste doit être
rapidement mise en place à ce titre
salué les accords européen sur le paquet
climat et la réduction de 55 % des
émissions de gaz à effet serre d'ici à
2030 adoptée sous la présidence
française ce que nous voulons c'est une
écologie positive du quotidien inventive
et réactive pour bâtir de nouveaux
modèles énergétiques et faire de la
france le premier grand pays au monde à
sortir de la dépendance aux énergies
fossiles par conséquent tout ce qui peut
renforcer et faciliter la production
d'énergie renouvelable pas dans le bon
sens
l'administration centrale et
déconcentrée madame le premier ministre
doivent véritablement accompagner le
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
et accélérer les transitions
énergétiques
je ne voit que trop de projets freiner
ou abandonnés sur le territoire par trop
de l'odeur et trop d'administration en
l'occurrence repenser le système de
santé c'est aussi l'urgence des français
vous l'avez évoqué longuement je n'y
reviens pas mais je sais que le
gouvernent mention poirat vous l'avez
vous même évoqué madame le premier
ministre vous avez rappelé les efforts à
travers le secteur de santé sans doute
ne sont ils pas ainsi monsieur rétail
aulas évoqué mais il n'empêche que dans
chacun de nos territoires chacun de nos
hôpitaux de nos hôpitaux locaux de nos
chu ont vu des moyens sans précédent mis
à leur disposition pour moderniser
l'hôpital la lutte contre les déserts
médicaux bien sûr nous y avons déjà
travaillé il ya des pistes nouvelles que
le ministre a ouvert et sur lesquels
nous allons continuer à travailler
ensemble
l'hôpital doit être repensé le président
a raison de vouloir lancer dès l'automne
les débats territoriaux pour une feuille
d'actions accéléré au plus près des
besoins des territoires enfin il nous
appartient d'assurer la sécurité des
comptes de nos concitoyens l'examen
prochain du texte de loi d'orientation
programmation pour le ministère de
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur et
contribuera nécessairement par ailleurs
nous serons attentifs à la mise en
oeuvre des conclusions des états
généraux de la justice remise très
prochainement au président de la
république l'enjeu est crucial s'agit de
renforcer l'efficacité de la justice de
la moderniser de répondre au malaise
existant parmi les professionnels de la
justice en somme en somme consolider le
pacte civique entre la nation et la
justice nous approuvons la méthode des
états généraux fait de larges
concertations ouverte de terrain
intégrant les usagers les professionnels
les élus autour des parties prenantes
nuit par la perspective d'amélioration
profonde cette méthode madame la
première ministre à votre proposition de
construire ensemble nous y souscrivons
enfin madame la première ministre ne
peut terminer mon propos sans prendre
quelques instants pour évoquer le crid à
l'herbe pousser en provenance des
territoires ultramarins vous l'avez
évoqué la tvo qui à plusieurs reprises
je vous en remercie le choix des
extrêmes amplifiée par un taux
d'abstention aux dernières élections et
l'expression inédite d'une réelle et
d'une profonde fracture les raisons sont
multiples mais nous ne devons pas
négliger l'influencent nocifs des
fausses informations et des
contre-vérités qui ont pu être rationné
beaucoup de moyens et ont émis mais il
ya encore un manque de dialogue un
manque de concertation et peut-être même
de différenciation sur ces territoires
nous devons collectivement
repenser la relation entre nos
territoires marins et les dans l'ultra
marin l'hexagone pour davantage de
confiance davantage de respect et
davantage de dialogue et davantage de
différenciation julie et surtout
s'inscrire au plus près des besoins
quotidiens de nos compatriotes
d'outre-mer pour conclure madame la
première ministre votre action visera
donc accompagner notre pays vers une
transition réussie qu'elle soit d'ordre
écologique numérique générationnelle ou
encore démocratique le tout dans un
contexte géopolitique inédits et des
plus instables à nos frontières
européennes la raison pour laquelle le
groupe r des pays vous accordera toute
sa confiance sera à vos côtés pour
rendre possible si réforme et je vous
remercie merci monsieur le président
donner la parole pour le groupe
communiste républicain
citoyen et écologistes madame la
présidente eliane assassi
[Applaudissements]
avec le sourire
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs les
ministres madame la première ministre la
france vit une situation politique
inédite pour la première fois dans le
cadre du quinquennat un président de la
république et son gouvernement ne
dispose pas du soutien d'une majorité
absolue à l'assemblée nationale pour la
première fois depuis trente ans un
gouvernement s'apprête à agir sur 100 la
confiance des parlementaires
comment emmanuel macron en est-il arrivé
là tout d'abord les élections en 2017 et
2022 sont le résultat non pas d'une
adhésion à un programme mais contre
l'extrême droite le chef de l'état nie
l'évidence le 22 juin il a fait mais
même que son élection s'est faite dieu
le site sur le fondement d'un projet
clair en me donnant une légitimité clair
or l'étape nouvelles de la crise
institutionnelle que nous vivons puise
sa source dans un hiatus démocratique
évident
emmanuel macron a vaincu madame le pen
grâce à l'électorat de gauche celui de
la droite lui étant déjà acquis dès le
premier tour et des millions d'électeurs
ont fait le choix de l'abstention à
l'évidence il faut imaginer un nouveau
régime parlementaire véritablement
ouvert aux citoyens en effet nous en
nous sommes arrivés là car ce qui est
rejeté aujourd'hui outre un bilan sur
lequel je reviendrai c'est la
verticalité d'un pouvoir méprisant d'une
dérive monarchique
emmanuel macron a failli dans l'exercice
démocratique du pouvoir et il a été
sanctionné en conséquence je le répète
il n'a pas de majorité absolue à
l'assemblée nationale enfin une raison
fondamentale a conduit à la crise que
nous connaissons
durant ces cinq années le président a
été perçu comme celui des riches parce
qu'il l'a été les chiffres sont là un
seul exemple en 2021 les salariés des
pdg du cac 40 on prête que les salaires
des pdg du cac 40
est-ce que doublé doivent faire le point
sur l'explosion des dividendes ou du
maintien malgré toutes les belles
déclarations gouvernementales de
l'évasion fiscale au niveau de 80 à 100
milliards d'euros par an soit près du
double du budget annuel de l'éducation
nationale le ruissellement n'a pas eu
lieu les salaires ou au mieux stagner le
plus urgent est temps pour vous de
supprimer l'impôt sur la fortune
mobilière la flat tax les heatpipes ont
pu poursuivre leur belle vie petits
arrangements fiscaux bien au chaud dans
le nid douillet de la macro ni le en
même temps aurait dû entraîner une
amélioration de la vie des salariés les
plus beaux et les plus pauvres
que nenni casse du droit du travail par
les ordonnances pénicaud baisse des apl
mise en cause des droits des chômeurs
par votre projet madame la première
ministre
accélération de la libéralisation du
transport ferroviaire contredisant son
essor écologique après la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
ce sont des milliers de chômeurs en
moins qui ont été indemnisées puisqu'il
faut avoir travaillé au moins six mois
et non plus quatre pour être prises en
charge il s'agit d'une réforme honteuse
alors que les actionnaires et financier
de tous poils s'engraissaient vous avez
appauvri des chômeurs nous savons que
durant la crise de l'aco vie de la
nation toute entière a fait un grand
effort pour permettre à notre pays à son
économie de passer l'épreuve ce que nous
avons pu constater aussi c'est que les
moyens existent est pour agir la
mobilisation financière qui a été
possible face à la copie doit être
renouvelée pour faire face à l'urgence
sociale éducative et écologique les
comptes d'apothicaire ne sont plus de
mise oui il est temps d'agir pour
redresser notre pays pour tracer un
avenir votre projet sur le pouvoir
d'achat n'est pas à la hauteur des
besoins il ne permettra pas de relancer
la mécanique économique pour la
consommation il ne répondra pas à la
détresse de millions de nos compatriotes
l'inflation galope porté par une
spéculation indigne il faut d'urgence
bloquer les prix des produits de
première nécessité et baisser le prix de
l'énergie carburant électricité et gaz
l'échec ça suffit 100 euros par 650
euros par là peuvent donner l'illusion
d'une aide comment imaginer qu'une monde
200 euros pour les étudiants en
difficulté leur permettra de se loger de
se nourrir d'acheter leur matériel il
faut une véritable allocation étudiante
2000 53 euros par mois quand nous le
proposons avons avec nos amis de la
nuque plus généralement il faut
augmenter les pensions et les salaires
c'est ça madame la première mini ce la
clé d'une amélioration réelle et pérenne
de la situation le smic à 1500 euros
n'est tout de suite est une nécessité
absolue pour des milliers de salariés
c'est le gouvernement qui peut donner le
la en matière salariale en augmentant le
smic qui par un effet domino entraînera
une augmentation générale des salaires
qu'est ce qui bloque
madame la première ministre qu'est ce
qui bloque le patronat le cac 40 la
situation politique
le signal fort envoyé par les électeurs
exigent que ce soit l'intérêt général
qui prime et pas l'intérêt de ceux qui
détiennent le pouvoir de l'argent il
faut immédiatement convoqué une
conférence nationale sur les salaires le
capital doivent röthlin rétribuer
dignement le travail agir pour le peuple
dans l'intérêt du peuple en écoutant le
peuple ce n'est certainement pas en
retardant l'âge de départ à la retraite
là aussi emmanuel mâcon s'il persiste ne
respecterait pas la volonté des
électeurs ils n'ont pas voté pour cette
mesure comme il ne l'avait pas fait en
2017 il exige au contraire la retraite à
60 ans agir
ce ne peut être mettre au travail des
bénéficiaires du rsa agir ce ne peut pas
ce ne peut pas être baisser les impôts
surtout pour les patrons avec une peine
baisse programmée de 7 milliards d impôt
de production mais tend d'ailleurs à mal
les finances
collectivités locales par la suppression
de la cvae ces dernières dans l'hexagone
comme en outre-mer sont en première
ligne face à la crise sociale il faut
compenser la hausse du coût de l'énergie
qui grèvent leurs budgets de même
l'augmentation pleinement justifiée mais
pour autant encore trop fait des
fonctionnaires territoriaux doit leur
être compensée faute de quoi le service
public en pâtira agir pour le pouvoir
d'achat c'est geler les loyers pour ceux
qui ne peuvent plus les payer le
logement doit redevenir devenir une
grande cause nationale et nous tenons à
votre disposition une ppl précise sur ce
sujet l'accès aux soins doit être une
priorité cessé de suivre les
recommandations des cabinets de conseil
comme mckinsey et capgemini
l'épidémie de coville a mis en évidence
la crise de notre système de santé à
l'hôpital et en ehpad ce qui exige de
les soustraire à la loi du marché alors
que la septième vague est là allez-vous
agir informer recruter équipés allez
vous construire payés dignement pour
casser la désertification médicale allez
vous assurez un remboursement d'ian
commençons par appliquer réellement le
100 %
l'éducation nationale est elle aussi en
danger il manque trois mille postes pour
la rentrée un exemple pour décrire la
situation
426 professeurs d'école admis dans
l'académie de versailles pour
1430 à pourvoir un effort financier
considérable doit être engagé le
développement du service public de
l'enseignement transport de la police à
l'hôpital en dépend cet effort financier
sera nécessaire pour une politique
industrielle et agricole fondée sur
l'hérault leur localisation et le
respect de la planète en si peu de temps
il n'est pas possible de nous et de nous
de vous répondre sur tous les points
madame la première ministre votre
logiciel de régression sociale et de
casse des services publics annoncés le
peuple n'en veut pas nous n'avons pas
d'illusions la réalité politique pousse
votre gouvernement vers la droite des
hémicycles et depuis cinq ans
la majorité sénatoriale a très souvent
soutenu les poussait libéral de monsieur
macron votre projet sur les retraites
par exemple obtiendra obtiendra à coup
sûr son soutien madame la première
ministre nous disons aussi attention à
toute tentative d'un jeu mortifère avec
le rassemblement national qui tourne
toujours et encore le dos à l'idée même
de progrès oui madame la première
ministre nous serons vigilants pour que
notre peuple soient préservés de la
violence libéral et de la haine et nous
porterons en permanence avec les députés
de la nuque l'espoir de progrès de
justice sociale et d'une transition
énergétique d'une urgence évidente en
somme nous opposerons à votre logiciel
libéral un logiciel de progrès de
transformation pour véritablement
répondre aux exigences populaires merci
venait mme la présidente
[Applaudissements]
la parole est au président que jean
claude requier pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
monsieur le président
monsieur le président à un prix un
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
membres du gouvernement mes chers
collègues je voudrais à mon tour saluer
votre nomination à tête du gouvernement
mais là la première ministre et lui
adresse erronée de mes collègues du
groupe rdse et à mon nom propre nos
meilleurs voeux de pleine réussite nous
savons votre tâche s'annonce ardue mais
notre pays nos concitoyens méritent que
vous trouviez la voie du succès car
c'est un fait incontestable que nous
nous situons bien un moment charnière de
notre histoire collective dans les
causes remonte à plusieurs décennies
assumant notre histoire dans toute sa
complexité ses épisodes glorieux comme
les puces sommes en l'emportant bien ni
mal dessiné un avenir propre est en
profonde mutation économique et social
qui regorge de tant de richesses mais
qui ne sait plus quelle est sa place
dans une économie mondialisée dans les
salles de décision saluée ap nous
constatons parfois une puissance de
l'innovation se dessine de plus en plus
bas en europe l'industrie recule
inexorablement ou que notre influence
culturelle s'amenuisent pour tout dire
c'est la définition même de notre
souvent à noter qu'issam mise en balance
mais quoi de plus normal donc dans un
monde désormais multipolaire pauvre pas
nous sommes pas de ceux qui se lamentent
sur un déclin irréversible de la france
englué dans des passions tristes du
nostalgie névrosé nous croyons contraire
aux vertus de l'action du progrès et des
aînés collective notre peuple comme à
chaque fois qui est confronté à des
choix difficiles oui nous venons de
traverser des années difficiles qui ont
durement éprouvé les esprits et les
corps série d'attentats terroristes
réveillez jaune pandémie le comider
aujourd'hui retour de l'inflation dans
toutes les épreuves ac société aurait pu
basculer dans l'irrationnel s'est divisé
en factions irréconciliables tel n'a pas
été le cas même si l'extrême ont su
capitaliser sur toutes les peurs pour
avancer leurs pires mortifère et pousser
leur avantage au risque cultivés à
violence politique symbolique voire
voire physique scrutin après scrutin
l'abstention sa racine chaque fois nous
déplorons et prend soin à l'avoir
compris et cause pour mieux en tirer les
leçons mais à chaque fois l'abstention
progress déplaça les contestations de
l'ue ont à la rue avec une montée en
puissance de la violence or nous devons
maintenant y mettre un terme
d'abord en rendre à innover et à le
porter à 8 et nationale qui a été trop
souvent galvaudé ces dernières décennies
les inégalités économiques et sociales
nourrissez de citoyenneté à plusieurs
vitesses qui n'est plus acceptable et
qui conduit dans le pire des cas au
séparatisme au contraire notre société a
besoin d'apaisement et de dialogue de
faire sentir à chacun quel que soit son
parcours qui fait pleinement partie de
la nation et que sa voix pèsera pour
cela nous conseillons dix fois
encourager le débat sous toutes ses
formes revitaliser le corps et des corps
intermédiaires mieux conjuguer
démocratie représentative et expression
directe nous appelons un véritable
sursaut de la conception de la
citoyenneté dans le prolongement des
propositions concrètes notre collègue
henri cabanel il ya urgence à recréer
les conditions d'une destinée commune
est de redonner aux jeunes la ville
selon lui de s'engager pour l'intérêt
général ni à moins tout ça restera vaine
cx sur nationale n'est pas érigée au
rang de priorité absolue en particulier
au moment où le rationalisme remis en
cause dans le drame au sénat au lierse
alisme ne va plus de soi la laïcité à
l'école est violemment contesté mais
aussi aux reculons dans les classements
internationaux
au pays de voltaire de pasteur et alors
que nous nous aurons des nouvelles mais
là ils finissent le travail à accomplir
reste considérable pour que les jeunes
soient demain des citoyens éclairés à
cette crise la démocratie une crise
économique et sociale dans les îles et
jaunes n'ont été que la phase la plus
exacerbée par les excès se sont exprimé
des préoccupations légitimes celle d'une
partie de la population qui se sent
aujourd'hui à l'écart de la
mondialisation heureuse
oublié de l'état avec cinq rubriques de
moins en moins présent et wc de la
croissance avec une douzaine de
désindustrialisation massive et peu
d'espoir de mobilité sociale victimes de
la fracture numérique
à l'heure où la dématérialisation de
masse même si je suis à lyon je passe
aussi à nos concitoyens de la ruralité
qui n'ont évidemment pas les mêmes
facilités d'accès que dans les zones
urbaines ont mobilité dite douce et
écologique mais cela ne signifie pas
qu'ils soient restés à l'écologie mais
trop souvent ils ont le sentiment d'être
pris de haut à propos de leur mode de
vie la transition écologique ne
fonctionnera pas si elle ne se fait pas
contre 6 contre de nos concitoyens dans
une logique logique purement punitive
nos régions y sommes évidemment et
attendons beaucoup de la version de la
radical dominique fond comme secrétaire
d'état à la réalité pour succéder à
l'excellent jeu idiot la ruralité n'est
pas une charge mais une chance pour la
france
la question du pouvoir d'achat d'autres
évidemment être au coeur des priorités
du gouvernement
l'explosion du coût des matières
premières affecte d'abord les plus
fragiles dans leur consommation de
première nécessité la hausse des prix
des actifs frappe durement notre modèle
économique est prise aux collectivités
territoriales des solutions pérennes
quand vous êtes retrouvé conscient
impératifs écologiques et soutenabilité
financière
malaria ministre toutes les démocraties
libérales sont aujourd'hui confrontés à
cette crise protéiforme qui revient
qu'au delà qui parfois séculaires
l'absence de majorité claire ne signifie
par pour autant
immobilisme et blocages nous avons le
sens de la sociabilité mon groupe dans
toute sa diversité est disposée à
travailler à vos côtés
sans esprit partisan ni idéologique mais
toujours en faveur de l'intérêt général
de nos concitoyens et de collectivités
et nous soyons dans votre discours de
politique générale les annonces en
matière de déco égalisation de la hache
que nous avions soutenu et la
renonciation des nerfs c'est dans cet
esprit constructif ouvert progressiste
et attaché à l'ordre public elles
devront travailler à nos propositions de
lois comme celle de henri cabanel sur la
citoyenneté nathalie delattre sur la
protection pénale des élus et rigole ça
vienne et ferroviaires j'aï le rouge sur
instruction des documents d'urbanisme
officiel milhac proposant un contrat
solidaire d'utilité publique elle nous
aurons d'autres propositions à soumettre
le territoire et vous connaissez notre
attention à la décentralisation
vous savez d'idées par là des choix
d'intérêt général nous restons
viscéralement attaché entre liberté de
vote il était de voir d'autres groupes
que beaucoup ici nous allons y mais en
secret dans tous les cas nous nous rions
rire réjouissons de voir que senna
trouve aujourd'hui une place
particulièrement dans le jeu une place
particulière dans le jeu institutionnel
ça se répartir les vertus de la
modération autorise s'il n'en pas douter
des interlocuteurs exigeant mais en
prennent du même sens de la brique à
rebours des vexé des populistes de tous
bords encore un qui est vrai par des
lendemains d'élections qui chante 2010
couvriront assez tôt qu'être un
parlementaire exige responsabilités et
gravité avoir pris au ministre de
données avec d'autres gouvernements des
gages de bonne volonté alors rassemblés
à notre sénat plus que jamais ce hameau
des territoires et des collectivités
si monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
pour le groupe indépendant république et
territoires je vais donner la parole au
président claude malhuret monsieur le
président
monsieur le président madame la première
ministre mme sheikh collègues depuis le
19 juin tout le monde proclame sa
victoire avec un art admirable de l'auto
persuasion
les uns ont gagné parce qu'ils n'ont pas
perdu les autres organes y est bien
qu'ils aient perdu
d'autres enfin croit avoir gagné parce
qu'ils n'ont pas compris qu'ils avaient
perdue on connaissait on connaissait les
victoires à la pyrrhus il y a maintenant
les défaites gagnante
la vérité est beaucoup plus simple et
brutale
et je m'étonne que personne n'en ai
parlé jusqu'ici
les deux vrais vainqueurs de ces
élections sont le populisme et
l'extrémisme on en a vu les premiers
résultats dès cet après-midi et le
déplorable spectacle à l'assemblée
nationale
lorsqu au premier tour de la
présidentielle les extrêmes recueille 57
% des suffrages
lorsque les uns multiplie le nombre de
leurs débuté par cinq et les autres par
dix c'est une gifle pour tous les partis
démocratiques tous
il y a cinq ans
la france était cité en exemple elle
échappé à la vague de populisme qui
frappe les démocraties et qui est donnée
trump bolton arrow le breakbeat urban et
quelques autres aujourd'hui elle est
rattrapé par la patrouille
elle ne doit son salut provisoire qu'à
une particularité historique alors
qu'ailleurs le populisme n'est que
d'extrême droite chez nous où l'école
apprend aux élèves adorent et camille
desmoulins et a préféré robespierre à
tocqueville il est coupé en deux ce
qu'ils empêchent d'arriver au pouvoir
pour le moment mais les extrêmes sont
moins éloignés qu'on le pense ce qui les
rapproche est bien plus fort que ce qui
les sépare la haine de l'europe et de
l'otan l'antiaméricanisme à sa poutine
l'ukraine les retraites les programmes
économiques délirant le complotisme le
soutien aux antilles va axer les news la
posture tribunicienne l'obsession du
soupçon et de la dénonciation
ce qui les sépare leurs histoires
respectives et leurs chefs qui se
détestent certains croient leur
hybridation impossible elle gagne chaque
jour du terrain regardez les transfuges
les militants qui se font des clins
d'oeil les report massif du deuxième
tour des législatives
et il ya chaque jour un peu moins de
différences entre la xénophobie des uns
et le racialisme des autres qui
hiérarchise les gens selon leur degré de
mélanine est ce qu'il y a quelqu'un ici
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un ici qui
croient que taboo apps ou danièle obono
l'ami de l'antisémite corps been sont
anti raciste
aujourd'hui au delà des apparences
électorale la france voit s'affronter un
pôle européen et républicains et un pôle
populistes et nationalistes le le péno
mélenchonisme ce sont les jumeaux de la
ruine qui peut affirmer
qui peut affirmer que nous n'assisterons
pas demain comme en italie au
regroupement des indices et des fachos
fâché ou pas au profit de celui qui aura
terrassé l'autre car ce qui les sépare
c'est aussi la stratégie pour les
mélenchonistes la taille du ko à
l'assemblée et du chaos dans la rue pour
les lepénistes la respectabilité au
service d'un objectif après le chaos
nous à ma gauche le général tapioca du
vieux-port chauffée à blanc par les
résultats qu'il surestime
ressorts sont marc chisson marxisme
archi très passer son keynésianisme pour
cour de récré on augmente les dépenses
de 250 milliards et hop ça en ramène 267
dans une exaltation qui lui donne plus
que jamais l'air de parler depuis le
sommet d'une barricade l' expert en
nivologie depuis le trotskisme de sa
jeunesse jusqu'au soutien inconditionnel
à poutine a ressorti le programme commun
du frigo elle a imposé au reste de la
gauche avec en prime l'entrée de la
france dans l'alliance bolivarienne
c'est un peu
c'est un peu là c'est un peu la yvette
horner de la politique
sans blog
son blog comporte une liste de 180 m
arrange et par mots clés
démocratie n'y figure pas
avec les phares en appui de pas mal de
médias prosterner comme des lapins dans
les phares il s'est décrétée premier
ministre le plus cocasse et que certains
l'ont cru après tout dans l' empire
romain on a bien nommé un cheval consul
à ma droite l'héritière du château de
montres tous que ça n'empêche pas de
parler au nom du peuple à une stratégie
plus intelligente donc plus dangereuse
oubliez le faire le pen qui n'a réussi
par ses outrances qu'à devenir le
maréchal pétrin
depuis deux mois le mot d'ordre c'est
pas de vagues c'est bien simple
maintenant quand elle passe à la télé
sourire jusqu'aux oreilles pas moi pas
moi sourire jusqu'aux oreilles
dent-blanche haleine fraîche et tout le
monde il est beau tout le monde il est
gentil
on croirait voir le canut et
plus les réponses
plus les républicains ex
plus les républicains expliquent qu'ils
sont dans l'opposition
plus elle sous-entend qu'elle n'exclut
pas de faire une fleur aux gouvernements
elle demande maintenant de siéger au
centre de l'hémicycle effet prendre des
cours de maintien ses troupes attention
à ce contre-pied ce pourrait bien être
le baiser qui tue pour la majorité où la
droite républicaine
ça n'a pas échappé aux insoumis qui
dénoncent déjà avec des cris d'orfraie
une collusion qui n'existe pas ces deux
extrémismes sont dangereux et nous
impose trois responsabilité la première
est d'éviter de leur courir après parce
que l'une des choses les plus tristes
dans ces élections c'est d'avoir vu des
bataillons entiers des républicains de
droite et de gauche emboîté le pas aux
extrémistes
quand d'antan deux départements des
responsables de la droite républicaine
refuse de suivre l'exemple du président
du sénat et d'appeler comme lui a voté
le 19 juin pour les candidats démocrates
contre les extrêmes
il y a un problème quand un candidat à
la primaire présidentielle annonce qu'il
voterait et moore au deuxième tour
contre macron il y a un problème mais le
plus navrant c'est le naufrage d'une
grande partie de la gauche après la
défaite de 2010 est le ps avait vendu
son siège en 2022 il a vendu son âme
adepte d'une adepte du plus c'est gros
plus ça marche
le mal nommé olivier faur ose comparer
l'alliance avec et les filles au front
populaire en faisant semblant de ne pas
voir l'éléphant dans la pièce le front
populaire étaient dirigées par la gauche
de gouvernement pas par le projet
insensé des insoumis le plus stupéfiant
c'est que les nouveaux pacsés
s'entendent à peu près comme des chats
dans un sac totalement opposés sur
l'europe et l'otan sur le nucléaire sur
la loi elle comrie sur la retraite à 60
ans sur la 6ème république
ils ne sont d'accord sur rien 15/09
cazeneuve delga cambadélis et beaucoup
d'autres l'ont bien compris c'est
l'identité des socialistes depuis le
congrès de tours qui disparaît quand on
passe de léon blum à léon trotsky c'est
la victoire posthume de gueule sur
jaurès ça sent l'histoire disait
mélangeant avec sa modestie habituelle
au lendemain de l'accord moi je trouve
plutôt que comme disait edouard herriot
ça sent l'andouillette pour parler
poliment la deuxième responsabilité des
démocraties et de comprendre les raisons
du vote populiste et les moyens de le
dégonfler continuer de prétendre que les
programmes qui les problèmes qui nourrit
cette vague néo this pas refuser depuis
30 ans interrogés sur ce qui se passe
est un vrai danger pour la démocratie le
danger d'avancé avec un bandeau sur les
yeux la troisième responsabilité des
démocrates c'est de réussir gouverner
avec une majorité relative est un défi
s'opposer aussi nous savons déjà que la
coalition où le pacte de gouvernement
n'auront pas lieu ne reste donc que la
méthode du cas par cas elle impose de
changer les habitudes
un gouvernement qui propose au lieu
d'imposer une opposition qui composent
au lieu d'empêcher majorité et
opposition républicains sont condamnés à
se supporter ne pas y parvenir serait la
recette infaillible de l'impuissance
face à la crise économique et aux défis
sociaux qui s'annonce ne pas y parvenir
n'entraînerait pas la prochaine fois la
victoire d'une famille contre l'autre
mais la défaite de tous face aux
populistes il paraît que la culture du
compromis n'existe pas en france il va
bien pourtant falloir s'y résoudre
autant dire ma vers la première ministre
qu'en entrant à matignon vous avez
accepté un nouveau job celui de
démineurs en chef même si sa majorité
vous êtes opposés la tâche ne me paraît
pas impossible au sénat elle suppose un
respect réciproque
ça tombe bien c'est la tradition de la
maison le groupe des indépendants
sera en tout cas fidèle à cette ligne de
conduite
elle est la seule qui répondent aux
défis auxquels est confronté le pays et
aux messages que nous ont envoyé les
français le 19 juin
[Applaudissements]
redonner la parole aux présidents
guillaume gand tard pour le groupe
écologie solidarité et territoires
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres madame la
première ministre
votre déclaration de politique générale
vient apporter quelques précisions
bienvenues
un propres et j'ai un projet pardon
présidentiel donc comme tout un chacun
n'avons pas saisi grand chose
l'exercice est réussi on en oublierait
presque vous gouverner depuis cinq ans
on comprend donc bien même si on le
déplore que vous vous dérober à la
conscience de l'assemblée nationale de
peur certainement d'être sanctionnés
parce pas six
après le revers historique de la
majorité présidentielle aux élections
législatives ou votre projet est arrivé
derrière celui de la nouvelle union
populaire au premier tour il est est de
votre responsabilité
de tendre la main aux oppositions
contrairement au président de la
république encore en proie au deuil de
sa toute puissance vous avez semblé vous
ouvrir au compromis parlementaire cette
perspective a malheureusement été
rapidement douchés par la suite de votre
déclaration ou à aucun moment la
négociation d'assemblée envisageable
c'est une bien curieuse conception du
régime parlementaire dont il va vous
falloir en urgence réapprendre la
pratique effectivement peut-être
s'inspirer du sénat après avoir
diabolisé la gauche écologiste avec une
violence inouïe après avoir voulu
l'exclure du champ républicain
il est effectivement difficile de lui
tendre la main hier encore le ministre
de l'intérieur curieusement promu malgré
son incapacité à organiser correctement
une élection régionale ou une finale de
la ligue des champions nous qualifiés
d'ennemis
renvoyer dos à dos comme le fait
également le président du sénat les
partisans du progrès social et
écologique et les héritiers de la courbe
et un de la collaboration se meurt de
haine et de division est proprement
scandaleux
madame la première ministre monsieur
président du sénat nous ne sommes pas un
danger pour la république l'affirmé tout
comme banaliser le rassemblement
national est une faute devant l'histoire
pertes et mon permettez-moi
solennellement à cette tribune d'appeler
toutes celles et ceux qui se considèrent
républicain qui endosse cet héritage de
progrès et de justice dont la gauche a
toujours été le moteur de s'écarter du
chemin
crépusculaire qui nous mène droit au
retour du fascisme au pouvoir
madame la première ministre votre
responsabilité en la matière est
considérable vos hésitations du mois de
juin ont permis l'arrivée de 89 députés
rn à l'assemblée les digues doivent être
battu c'est le dernier arrêt avant la
nuit noire
une chambre sans majorité absolue n'est
pas un drame c'est même une bonne
nouvelle à condition d'être clair sur
les valeurs et de se débarrasser du
scrutin majoritaire dont l'utilité n'est
plus et qui porte en lui une violence
politique dangereuse pour la démocratie
instaurons la proportionnelle et cessons
de faire campagne à coude anathèmes
comme aux grandes heures du
parlementarisme délibérons composons
prenant le temps de faire moins de lois
et de meilleures lois madame la première
ministre
engagé en collaboration avec le
parlement la refonte de nos institutions
rééquilibrer les pouvoirs entre
l'exécutif et le législatif mais
également entre paris et le reste de la
france vous avez clamer votre amour des
territoires il nous en faut surtout des
preuves
un nouvel acte de décentralisation une
autonomie renforcée pour les territoires
qui le désirent et oh purée au premier
rang desquels la corse et surtout
surtout des moyens financiers sur la
défense des droits humains et notamment
des droits des femmes vous nous
trouverez également à vos côtés alors
que les états unis sont dans une
régression moyenâgeuse la france doit
envoyer au monde un signal d'espoir et
de progrès pour sous verre pour ce faire
nous vous proposons de rédiger ensemble
avec les françaises et les français une
charte du droit des femmes qui viendrait
se rattacher au préambule notre
constitution madame la première ministre
une question simple vous engagez vous
apportez une révision constitutionnelle
pour consacrer le droit à l'avortement
pour le reste je crains que le
dogmatisme et l'idéologie présidentielle
nous empêche de trouver tout terrain
d'entente les défis de notre temps
nécessite plus de puissance publique or
votre double logique et xénon raid
exonéré d'un pôle les milliardaires et
les grandes entreprises qui
s'enrichissent indûment pendant les
crises et désendetter le pays à marche
forcée va produire exactement inverse
madame la première ministre j'ai préparé
la suite de mon propos avec eléonore 18
ans louis seize ans et nathan 19 ans en
observation dans mon dans mon équipe il
vous écoute ce soir à travers eux je
veux me faire l'écho d'une partie de
notre jeunesse qui angoisse dans un
monde rendue de plus en plus incertain
par le retour de la guerre et le péril
climatique
l'écho de notre jeunesse qui
s'inquiètent de sa capacité à vivre sur
la terre dans les prochaines décennies
inquiétude à laquelle enfermé dans votre
déni des limites planétaires et dans
votre illusion techniciste d'une
écologie du progrès vous ne répondez pas
l'écho de notre jeunesse qui cherche du
sens à son activité professionnelle et
qui refusent de contribuer à la
destruction de la planète opérée par le
capitalisme qui n'a plus d'autres fins
que l'accumulation un signe de richesse
on ne retrouve dans vos propos que peu
de traduction concrète de la
planification écologique brandi pour les
besoins de la campagne il y a pourtant
tellement à faire pour repenser nos
modes de vie pour protéger le vivant
pour recouvrer notre souveraineté pour
lutter contre l'explosion des prix de
l'énergie grâce aux renouvelables pour
transformer notre agriculture vers le
bio pour rénover rénové réellement les
logements pour relocaliser des activités
économiques et industrielles vertueuse
et créer des emplois par centaines de
milliers dans la bifurcation écologique
pour créer des perspectives plein de
sens pour cette jeunesse qui désespère
des pouvoirs publics je le fais l'écho
d'une partie de notre jeunesse qui
souffre de plus en plus de la précarité
et qui est la première victime de
l'inflation galopante
pendant que les profiteurs de guerre
s'enrichissent honteusement les coûts de
ces étudiants qui se aux murs de
parcours su voix l'université française
dépérir et qui désespèrent de voir que
le seul projet que vous portez à leur
endroit et le service national universel
symbolisée par le rattachement funès du
secrétariat d'état à la jeunesse au
ministère des armées l'écho de ces
jeunes aidés c'est moins jeunes qui
souffre de la dégradation continue des
services publics des fermetures des
classes de la pénurie d'enseignants qui
s'inquiètent encore alors que ressurgit
le coc vide de la désertification
médicale des fermetures de l'ivoire de
services d'urgence entier qui sont
horrifiés de constater l'état déplorable
de nos crèches et de nos ehpad
les coûts en fin de notre jeunesse et de
nos compatriotes ultramarins qui
souffrent des mêmes maux décuplée qui
expriment leur souffrance et leur
désarroi depuis plusieurs années et pour
qui votre seule réponse est de les
rattacher au ministère de l'intérieur en
pleine dérive sécuritaire madame les
ministes de grâce et partez épargner
leur le préfet l'allemand madame la
première ministre quelle réponse
apporter vous à notre jeunesse votre
projet sur le pouvoir d'achat et votre
budget rectificatif sont presque vides
lors des débats parlementaires nous vous
invitons à accepter les propositions de
la nuque pour les enrichir le smic à
1500 euros ça a été rappelé la garantie
d'autonomie à 1000 euros le relèvement à
10% du point d'indicé de la fonction
publique le blocage des prix des loyers
et des produits de première nécessité
renoncer également à votre inutile
réforme des retraites et à votre
conteuse réforme du rsa elles n'ont pas
de majorité ni dans le pays ni au
parlement madame la première ministre
nous serons une opposition exigeante
pour produire le shop d'égalité dans
notre pays a besoin pour protéger de
toute urgence autre environnement et
pour rénover notre démocratie si
majorité il n'y a pas c'est que vous
n'aurez pas voulu et vous porterez la
responsabilité du blocage des
institutions et de l'immobilisme du pays
j'espère que votre sens de l'intérêt
général et vos talents de négociatrice
nous éviterons d'en arriver là merci
merci je vais
donner la parole
pour la réunion administrative des
sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste d'
aucun gros à monsieur stéphane ravier v
3 minutes
monsieur le président madame le premier
ministre mes chers collègues
de la promesse d'un gouvernement très
resserré à la nomination de 41 membres
en passant par le maintien voire la
promotion des ministres en charge de la
france en grand en grand en sauvagement
en grand remplacement en grand des
classements et en grand enfermement je
laissais pas vous mes chers collègues
mais moi j'ai la douloureuse sensation
de vivre un jour sans fin tant ce
gouvernement born 2 aurait pu s'appeler
castex 4 ou encore edouard philippe 6
ce retour permanent en arrière aurait pu
être une cure de jouvence s'il ne
s'agissait pas d'une nouvelle cure de
souffrance vous voulez madame le premier
ministre renouveau démocratique sans
vote de confiance du parlement sans
ministère des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales et en
conservant un garde des sceaux ministre
du laxisme judiciaire et du grand
encouragement mis en examen par la cour
de justice de la république vous
choisissez de reconduire à son poste les
ministres du grand remplacement de
l'intérieur désormais connu comme celui
du mensonge et de l'humiliation de notre
pays suite au désastre des razzias et de
l'hyper violence commise au stade de
l'anti-france vous voulez lutter contre
le séparatisme de l'islam et vous nommé
ministre de la ville et du logement un
maire favorable au droit de vote des
étrangers à la multiplication des
mosquées et à leur financement public
vous prétendez un kit vous inquiétez du
pouvoir d'achat des français tout en
conservant le ministre du grand
effondrement économique et du grand
déclassement social qui a accru la dette
publique de 600 milliards d'euros en
cinq ans seuls la moitié de cette somme
de ce gouffre étant imputable à la crise
qu vide
l'ancien ministre de la santé le
ministre de tous les enfermements
physique comme démocratique largement
visés par la justice administrative pour
impréparation et mensonges durant la
première vague coded est devenu lui le
porte parole du gouvernement mais quel
symbole pour lui succéder à la santé
vous avez choisi de nommer ministre pro
masque provoque propre à ce vaccin dans
l'âtre et déjà honni des professionnels
de santé
car adeptes du tri des patients en
réponse à à l'engorgement des urgences
plutôt l'intégration des migrants que la
réintégration des soignants vous voulez
plus d'écologie s'entendait de localisme
la ruralité à son secrétariat d'état
mais elle n'a pas en revanche les moyens
humains et financiers dont bénéficie la
politique de la ville cache sexe on le
sait de la politique d'immigration avec
ses milliards d'euros et que dire du
ministre de l'éducation plutôt de la
rééducation et du vivre ensemble
obligatoire pape et du oxm de la
déconstruction de notre identité humaine
et nationales dont la nomination a été
saluée par le grand timonier de l'islamo
gauchisme qu'est jean luc mélenchon
quand quant à la ministre la culture ou
de la des cultures elle conseillait déjà
le président quand il déclarait qu'il
n'y avait pas de culture française il
n'y a même pas de ministère de la
famille à l'heure où les démographes
annoncent que les français seront
minoritaires chez eux dans quelques
dizaines d'années dans le contexte
d'hyper crise que nous traversons vous
proposer de la continuité vous rajoutez
donc de la crise à toutes les crises
manifestement mes chers collègues à
travers la composition de ce
gouvernement force est de constater
qu'il n'ya pas que les non vaccinés
emmanuel macron décidé d'emmerdés c'est
désormais l'ensemble des français je
serai là quand à moi pour m'y opposer je
veux croire que je ne serai pas le seul
madame la premier ministre ou répondre
aux orateurs
merci monsieur merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je vous remercie tout d'abord pour la
richesse de ce débat
dans la situation inédite que connaît
notre pays le sénat sera plus que jamais
un pôle d'équilibré et de stabilité
je connais votre capacité à dépasser les
postures et les clivages pour imaginer
des solutions
cet esprit de dialogue qui permet de
nourrir les travaux législatifs
des apports de tous les groupes doit
nous inspirer le bicamérisme si
profondément inscrit au coeur de notre
démocratie est une illustration pratique
de la capacité à rechercher des
compromis durable à trouver les réponses
équilibrée et efficace
j'en ai fait l'expérience au cours de la
précédente législature sur les projets
de loi que j'ai porté en tant que
ministre je pense par exemple à la
réforme de la sncf une réforme
nécessaire
certains diront courageuse trop
longtemps différée que nous avons
construit ensemble
des textes sur lesquels les assemblées
peuvent parvenir à un accord sont
souvent plus solide les amendements
nourrie par la connaissance des
collectivités territoriales éclairé par
les travaux de contrôle et d'information
des commissions du sénat permettent de
répondre aux priorités des français sans
céder aux solutions toutes faites new
mouvement d'une actualité fébriles les
propositions de lois notamment celles
qui résultent des travaux pluraliste des
commissions d'enquêté des missions
d'information ont bien sûr vocation à
enrichir le travail législatif
monsieur le président retailleau merci
d'avoir évoqué en même temps des valeurs
celles de la république et en même temps
une méthode celle du dialogue bicaméral
auquel je suis profondément attaché
devant votre assemblée qui incarne les
vertus du débat dans le respect de
l'autre je veux réaffirmer l'engagement
de son gouvernement à bâtir des
solutions communes sans demander à
quiconque de renoncer à ce qu il est de
toutes mes forces je lutterai contre
cette fiole cette france en pièces
détachées dont vous avez parlé dont les
racines sont profondes je pense que
chacun peut le reconnaître nous ne
sommes probablement pas d'accord sur
tout n'allons pas nier nos divergences
et nous différence mais nous partageons
certainement des préoccupations nous
sommes probablement d'accord sur la
nécessité de renforcer notre
souveraineté industrielle et énergétique
pour permettre de renforcer la
conviction de notre destin commun sur la
nécessité de revenir à l'équilibré des
finances publiques fortement sollicités
par la pandémie et par les
bouleversements économiques issus du
conflit ukrainien sur celle d'améliorer
nos services publics en particulier dans
les quartiers prioritaires et les zones
rurales
l'inquiétude sur la situation de nos
finances publiques n'est peut-être pas
vécu avec la maman tu même intensité
partout les groupes
le gouvernement en a comme vous monsieur
le président retailleau une perception
très clair qui doit nous inciter à la
responsabilité et nous ne renonçons pas
à porter nos valeurs à l'échelle
européenne et mondiale
la présidence française l'a montré et
pour ma part je crois profondément que
la voix de la france porte et je suis
certaine que la manière dont nous avons
traversé la crise ensemble était la
bonne notamment grâce aux quoi qu'il en
coûte qui a permis de protéger nos
entreprises et nos emplois
alors vous le voyez monsieur le
président retailleau vouloir construire
des compromis ça ne veut pas dire être
d'accord sur tout
monsieur le président kenner j'ai bien
écouté vos propos vos critiques souvent
caricaturale et vos commentaires vos
propositions était plus discrète six
années une accumulation d'impôts et de
taxes mais monsieur le président canard
je vous rejoins la prise en compte des
outre mer est une exigence absolue les
départements et les collectivités
d'outre-mer sont une des grandes
richesses de notre république je les dis
cet après midi devant les députés
je leur dis devant vous nous répondrons
à l'appel de fort de france qu'ont lancé
il y a quelques jours les collectivités
mais monsieur le président caennais je
dois dire que dans cette enceinte j'ai
été surprise par vaux procès d'intention
juger juger nous sur nos actes et
retrouvons-nous peut-être sur ses actes
et quand vous annoncez vouloir être
constructif je le prends comme une lueur
d'espoir
monsieur le président patriat je partage
votre engagement pour l'action pour
répondre à l'urgence climatique
repenser notre système de santé pour
tirer les enseignements des états
généraux de la justice pour accélérer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
nous agirons sur tous ces sujets et nous
le ferons dans la concertation
monsieur le président marseille vous
avez souligné le caractère inédit en
france de notre situation politique mais
beaucoup moins originale lorsqu'on le
regarde au delà de nos frontières
comme vous le dites souvent monsieur le
président marseille nous devons nous
projeter dans l'avenir et l'europe nous
y aide la souveraineté c'est notre
capacité à peser et affronter les crises
plusieurs travaux du sénat avait vu
juste sur notre forte dépendance aux
industries étrangères en matière
pharmaceutique par exemple notre
souveraineté doit être pensée dans un
cadre européen
une europe plus forte c'est une france
plus forte
cette france plus forte naîtra de notre
dialogue et je vous remercie d'avoir
déjà mis des propositions sur la table
madame la présidente à ça si je partage
vos préoccupations face à la
désespérance sociale d'une partie de nos
concitoyens
nous ne pouvons accepter de laisser
s'éloigner de la démocratie et de
l'élection mais je suis convaincu que le
smic à 15 cents euros c'est l'assurance
du tassement des progressions de
salaires pour tous sur ces sujets les
solutions miracles sont souvent des
mirages et pèse fortement sur la
défiance de nos concitoyens
la réflexion qui s'engagera à l'automne
sous l'égide du président de la
république sur l'avenir de nos
institutions devra prendre en compte la
défiance exprimée dans les dernières
élections là aussi c'est par une
approche pluraliste que nous pourrons
construire des réponses utiles et
équilibrée
merci tout d'abord pour vous voeux de
réussite monsieur le président recueille
et merci pour votre bienveillante votre
bienveillance et votre optimisme car
c'est bien de la réussite de notre pays
dont il est question alors vous l'avez
dit monsieur le président et c'est une
préoccupation partagée par l'ensemble
des groupes l'état et les collectivités
doivent dresser ensemble
la liste des défis à relever identifier
les leviers à activer et les moyens à
mobiliser
l'action publique des collectivités
territoriales doit pouvoir s'appuyer sur
une visibilité dans leurs compétences et
leur qu'on dise les conditions de leur
action nous construirons donc ensemble
un agenda territoriales j'ai confiance
dans notre dans notre dialogue et notre
capacité à apporter des réponses au plus
près de nos concitoyens
je partage votre diagnostic
monsieur le président malhuret les
français ont exprimé des doutes et une
demande d'actions
l'abstention est le signe d'une
démocratie en souffrance d'une perte de
confiance dans l'action publique nous ne
pouvons et ne devons pas laisser le
champ à ceux qui voudraient revenir sur
nos acquis démocratiques
les évolutions que nous pouvons observer
dans d'autres pays nous rappelle que la
démocratie est une lutte de tous les
jours que les combats pour les valeurs
de liberté d'égalité de fraternité de
laïcité doit sans cesse être sans cesse
être repris pour cette raison aussi je
suis convaincu que nous pourrons
construire des majorités d'action car
les français n'ont pas choisi le blocage
de nos institutions
la nécessité de construire des compromis
pour répondre aux attentes des français
je l'identifient comme vous monsieur le
président gontard je ne je vous demande
de ne pas nous nous juger sur les
intentions que vous nous prêter mais
bien sur nos actes nous allons apprendre
à travailler ensemble
à vrai dire nous avons déjà commencé à
le faire ces dernières années mais il
nous faut aller plus loin
comme vous nous y avait invité monsieur
le président du sénat dans votre
courrier nous aurons bientôt l'occasion
d'échanger sur les modalités à mettre en
place pour que le dialogue soit le plus
fructueux sur les réformes que nous
allons engager
clemenceau lui même fini par déclarer
les événements montrent appris qu'il
fallait donner aux peuples le temps de
la réflexion le temps de la réflexion
c'est le sénat on pourrait ajouter que
c'est le temps du dialogue je vous
remercie de tout ce que le sénat pourra
apporter à notre pays dans cette période
inédite
merci madame le premier
[Applaudissements]
merci
mes chers collègues je vais maintenant
levé la séance notre prochaine séance
aura lieu le mardi 12 juillet à 14h30 et
elle commencera par l'éloge funèbre de
notre regretté collègue catherine
fournier la séance est levée